This episode is brought to you by the Lloyd's 5K House Deposit, and this is something that was last seen in 1996. Yeah, so the 1990s looks now like a lost golden age of prosperity and positivity, doesn't it? Think of the sort of the advent of the Blair administration in 1997, all the enthusiasm and excitement that surrounded that, the economic growth at the time, the technological developments, the sort of sense of an endless golden summer where everybody is listening to Blair and Oasis and looking forward to to buying their first houses, and that of course takes us to mortgages. Now, the good news is that in a nod to the 1990s, Lloyds are offering 5K deposit mortgages to first-time buyers. So search 5K first-time buyer. 1996 average first-time buyer deposits are based on ONS data. Subject to status, your home may be repossessed if you don't keep up repayments and conditions
本期节目由劳埃德银行5K房屋首付赞助，这是自1996年以来首次出现的产品。是的，现在的1990年代看起来就像一个失落的繁荣与积极的黄金时代，不是吗？想想1997年布莱尔政府上台时的那种热情和兴奋，当时的经济增长，技术发展，那种仿佛每个人都在听着布莱尔和绿洲乐队的歌，期待着购买第一套房子的无尽黄金夏日的感觉，当然，这让我们想到了抵押贷款。现在，好消息是，为了向1990年代致敬，劳埃德银行正在为首次购房者提供5K首付抵押贷款。所以请搜索“5K首次购房者”。1996年首次购房者的平均首付基于英国国家统计局的数据。受状态限制，如果您不按时还款，您的房屋可能会被收回，并适用相关条件。
apply. Your summer travels deserve an upgrade. With select Chevrolet, Buick, GMC, and Cadillac vehicles connected by OnStar, you can stream, game, and more on the go. Whether you're headed to a music festival or a cottage getaway, you can access hundreds of apps on Google Play right from your center display. Explore OnStar Tech today at OnStar.ca and discover how to take your summer to the next level. OnStar. Better never stops. A short memorial of the state of the realm. The perils are many great and imminent, great in respect of both the persons and the matters. Persons, the Queen's Majesty, who plays the part of the patient.
您的夏季旅行值得升级。通过OnStar连接的精选雪佛兰、别克、GMC和凯迪拉克汽车，您可以随时随地进行流媒体播放、游戏等操作。无论您是前往音乐节还是去度假小屋，都可以直接从中央显示屏访问Google Play上的数百个应用程序。立即在OnStar.ca探索OnStar技术，了解如何将您的夏季体验提升到一个新的水平。OnStar，追求卓越，永不止步。一份关于王国状况的简短备忘录。危险既多又大且迫在眉睫，在人员和事务方面都很严重。人员方面，女王陛下，她扮演着忍耐者的角色。
The Pope, the King of France and Spain, as the authors and workers on her. The Queen of Scots as the surgeon's knife, whereby the matters shall be attempted against the Queen's Majesty. The matters. For the recovery of the tyranny to the Pope, which of late years hath been discovered and so weakened. The eviction of the Crown of England from the Queen's Majesty, to set it upon the head of the Queen of Scots. Changing the estate of England to popery, which cannot be accomplished while the Queen's Majesty liveth, nor so assuredly and plausibly any way as by putting the Crown of England upon the Queen of Scots' head. Hi everybody, that was rather downbeat, indeed positively gloomy, briefing.
教皇、法国国王和西班牙国王，作为针对她的策划者和执行者。苏格兰女王作为外科医生的手术刀，由此将针对女王陛下采取行动。事务方面。为了恢复教皇的暴政，这种暴政近年来已被发现并削弱。将英格兰王冠从女王陛下手中夺走，戴在苏格兰女王的头上。将英格兰的国体转变为天主教，这在女王陛下在世时无法实现，也没有比将英格兰王冠戴在苏格兰女王头上更稳妥、更冠冕堂皇的方法了。大家好，那是一份相当低落，甚至可以说是阴郁的简报。
There was written in the early months of the year 1569 by Sir William Cecil, who was the chief minister to Queen Elizabeth I. So Elizabeth I, perhaps the most celebrated of all England's monarchs, had at this point been on the throne of England for just over a decade. She is 35 years old. She is the second daughter of King Henry the 8th. So England has broken from Rome. The Reformation has taken place.
这是1569年初由伊丽莎白一世女王的首席大臣威廉·塞西尔爵士所写。所以伊丽莎白一世，也许是英国所有君主中最著名的一位，此时已经在英国王位上坐了十多年。她今年35岁。她是亨利八世国王的第二个女儿。所以英格兰已经与罗马决裂。宗教改革已经发生。
However, even after a decade, Elizabeth remains embattled. She feels herself threatened by enemies within and enemies without. and that is the subject of this epic new series in which we will be delving into the realm of Elizabeth I and her various challenges, not least the Queen of Scots, Mary Queen of Scots. So, Tom, take us through William Cecil's briefing paper because he sets out perfectly there the challenge that we're going to be discussing in this series. Well, the metaphor in that briefing paper is a very brutal one. I mean, it's kind of cundering up an image of Elizabeth as a patient who's been strapped. down and the king of Spain, the king of France, the pope are descending on her with their butcher's knives. And the worst blade that they have is the Queen of Scots, Mary Stewart. And so, as you said,
然而，即使十年过去了，伊丽莎白仍然处于困境中。她感到自己受到来自内部和外部敌人的威胁。这就是这个史诗般的新系列的主题，我们将深入探讨伊丽莎白一世的领域以及她面临的各种挑战，尤其是苏格兰女王，玛丽·斯图亚特。那么，汤姆，带我们了解一下威廉·塞西尔的简报，因为他在那里完美地阐述了我们将在这个系列中讨论的挑战。嗯，那份简报中的隐喻非常残酷。我的意思是，它唤起了一种形象，伊丽莎白就像一个被绑住的病人，而西班牙国王、法国国王、教皇正带着屠刀向她走来。而他们拥有的最锋利的刀刃就是苏格兰女王，玛丽·斯图亚特。所以，正如你所说，
this is a very downbeat report and the briefing that he goes on to list all the challenges that he sees his mistress, Queen Elizabeth, is facing. So Elizabeth is on the throne of England as a Protestant queen. But the two most powerful monarchies in Christendom, Spain and France, are both Catholic. And so these two monarchies, in alliance with the papacy, which it goes without saying is also Catholic, are very keen to see England return to the Catholic fold. And Cecil sees it as his job to stop that happening. But he also feels this is a massive, massive task because the prospects of England returning to Catholicism, as he sees it, are actually very, very real. So the issue for Cecil and for all English Protestants is that the country's future, as Protestant,
这是一份非常低落的报告，他在简报中列出了他所看到的他的女主人伊丽莎白女王所面临的所有挑战。伊丽莎白作为一位新教女王坐在英国王位上。但基督教世界中最强大的两个君主国，西班牙和法国，都是天主教国家。因此，这两个君主国与教皇结盟（不用说，教皇也是天主教的），非常渴望看到英格兰回归天主教阵营。塞西尔认为阻止这种情况发生是他的工作。但他同时也觉得这是一项极其艰巨的任务，因为在他看来，英格兰回归天主教的前景实际上是非常、非常现实的。所以对塞西尔和所有英国新教徒来说，问题在于国家的未来，作为新教国家，
hangs really by a single thread. And this thread is Elizabeth's life, because she rules famously as a virgin queen, which means she has no child, she has no heir. And that in turn means that if Elizabeth is toppled from her throne, by assassination perhaps, or maybe by armed invasion, then who is best place to succeed her? And the answer to that is someone we have done an entire series about on the rest of history, and that is Mary Queen of Scots. So she is Elizabeth's cousin, terrible taste in husbands, hanging out with a squad in which everyone is called Mary, very kind of glamorous and romantic, but an incredible third. threat to Elizabeth because she is a Catholic.
真的悬于一线。而这根线就是伊丽莎白的生命，因为她以童贞女王的身份统治，这意味着她没有孩子，没有继承人。这反过来意味着，如果伊丽莎白被推翻，也许是通过暗杀，或者也许是通过武装入侵，那么谁最适合继承她呢？答案就是我们在《历史的其余部分》中做过一整个系列节目的人，那就是苏格兰女王玛丽。她是伊丽莎白的表亲，丈夫品味极差，和一群都叫玛丽的人混在一起，非常迷人且浪漫，但对伊丽莎白来说是一个难以置信的威胁，因为她是天主教徒。
And so getting the Catholic Mary onto Elizabeth's throne, you know, the kings of France and Spain couldn't be happier at the prospect because they regard Protestant England pretty much as the United States today regards Iran as a kind of a rogue state to be toppled. So to pursue that parallel, when the United States attacked Iran, the thinking in Washington and in Israel was that that would weaken the regime because there were lots of people in Iran who chafed against the regime and in fact there had been riots earlier this year
所以，让天主教徒玛丽登上伊丽莎白的王位，你知道，法国和西班牙的国王们对这个前景感到再高兴不过了，因为他们看待新教的英格兰，就像今天美国看待伊朗一样，将其视为一个需要被推翻的流氓国家。为了追溯这个类比，当美国攻击伊朗时，华盛顿和以色列的想法是，这将削弱该政权，因为伊朗有很多人对该政权感到不满，事实上今年早些时候还发生了骚乱，
there had been the student protests there had been all the killings and whatnot. Now in the 16th century, if you're in the court of France or Spain, presumably you think very similar things because you look at England and you say, well, Protestantism is only a recent transplant
发生了学生抗议，还有各种杀戮等等。现在在16世纪，如果你在法国或西班牙的宫廷里，大概你会想类似的事情，因为你看着英格兰，你会说，嗯，新教只是最近才移植到英格兰身体上的，
onto the body of England and perhaps there are actually a lot of people who can't wait to be rid of this mad, regime that they've got. Is that right? It is. And Cecil thinks it too. I mean, he is also painfully aware that Protestantism in England has very shallow roots and that essentially outside London and the southeast, where it's really pretty strong by now, most of the English, I think, remain instinctively Catholic. I mean, maybe not militantly Catholic, but instinctively Catholic. And in the north, so in the furthest most regions, maybe in Wales, in Cornwall, and particularly in the north of
也许实际上有很多人迫不及待地想摆脱他们现在拥有的这个疯狂的政权。是这样吗？是的。塞西尔也这么认为。我的意思是，他也痛苦地意识到，新教在英格兰的根基非常浅，本质上在伦敦和东南部之外，虽然现在那里已经相当稳固了，但大多数英国人，我认为，仍然本能地是天主教徒。我的意思是，也许不是激进的天主教徒，但本能上是天主教徒。而在北方，在最遥远的地区，也许在威尔士，在康沃尔，特别是在英格兰的北部，
England. There, I think there is a kind of more militant strain of Catholicism that is aching to see the old ways brought back. And so Cecil's great anxiety is not just about foreign intervention, Spain and France or whatever, but the fact that England is full of potential traitors. So that feels very modern, actually, doesn't it? It feels very 20th century. The idea that you have two ideologically opposed blocks, but within each one, there is a tremendous paranoia about about the enemy within. I mean, I think it would be very familiar to anyone who's read La Care's Cold War novels, the Smiley novels, because there is a kind of Cold War context to this conflict.
在那里，我认为有一种更激进的天主教倾向，渴望看到旧习俗回归。所以塞西尔最大的焦虑不仅是关于外国干预，西班牙和法国什么的，而是英格兰充满了潜在的叛徒。这感觉非常现代，不是吗？感觉非常20世纪。那种你有两个意识形态对立的集团，但在每一个集团内部，对内部敌人都存在巨大的偏执。我的意思是，我认为任何读过勒卡雷冷战小说，即史迈利系列小说的人都会非常熟悉，因为这场冲突有一种冷战背景。
So there are conflicts being fought out beyond England on foreign battlefields between Protestants and Catholics, and this is going to be part of the story that we're telling in this series. But you also have this war going on in the shadows. You have spy chiefs. they are employing code breakers, they are employing double agents, they have dirty tricks departments, the plots and the narratives will be very, very familiar to anyone who has read contemporary spy espionage thrillers. And Cecil, when he is warning about plots to topple Elizabeth and to replace her with the Catholic Mary, I mean, he is not crying wolf.
所以，在英格兰之外的外国战场上，新教徒和天主教徒之间正在进行冲突，这将是我们在这个系列中讲述的故事的一部分。但你也有这场在阴影中进行的战争。你有间谍头子，他们雇佣密码破译员，他们雇佣双重间谍，他们有肮脏手段部门，这些阴谋和叙事对于任何读过当代间谍惊悚小说的人来说都会非常、非常熟悉。而塞西尔在警告推翻伊丽莎白并用天主教徒玛丽取代她的阴谋时，我的意思是，他并不是在危言耸听。
These are really present dangers. there are conspiracies that are kind of brewing all the time. There are codes that he needs to have cracked. You know, there are moles buried deep within the establishment. So they didn't have the word spy so much. They used the word intelligentser, but you could imagine a novel called Tinker Taylor Soldier, intelligentser, and it would echo lots of the kind of Le Carre themes.
这些都是非常现实的危险。阴谋一直在酝酿。他需要破解密码。你知道，有鼹鼠深埋在体制内部。所以他们当时并没有“间谍”这个词，他们用的是“情报人员”这个词，但你可以想象一本名为《锅匠、裁缝、士兵、情报人员》的小说，它会呼应许多勒卡雷式的主题。
But having said that, as well as this kind of story of espionage, We will also be seeing some of the greatest and most dramatic episodes of the age. So we will be in Paris as the streets run red with the blood of Protestants on the St. Bartholomew's Day massacre. And we will be out on the ocean wave on the Pacific as top son of Devon, Francis Drake, carves out a name for himself as one of the greatest heroes of the age, or if you are Spanish, of course, one of the greatest pirates of the age. and we will be going to the low countries as well, the scene of the Dutch Revolt, one of the most seismic episodes in European history. And then the climax of this series, we will be in Fotheringay Castle on the 8th of February 1587. And there we will be witnessing an execution that will reverberate across Europe and will make inevitable the launching by Spain of a day. great armada, and that will be the climax of the series. Very exciting, very exciting,
但话虽如此，除了这种间谍故事之外，我们还将看到那个时代一些最伟大、最戏剧性的事件。所以我们将身处巴黎，看着街道被圣巴托罗缪大屠杀中新教徒的鲜血染红。我们将航行在太平洋的波涛上，德文郡的杰出人物弗朗西斯·德雷克将为自己赢得那个时代最伟大的英雄之一的名声，或者如果你是西班牙人，当然，是那个时代最伟大的海盗之一。我们也将前往低地国家，那里是荷兰起义的现场，这是欧洲历史上最震撼的事件之一。然后是这个系列的最高潮，我们将于1587年2月8日在福瑟林盖城堡。在那里，我们将目睹一场将在整个欧洲引起回响的处决，并将使西班牙不可避免地发动伟大的无敌舰队，那将是这个系列的高潮。非常令人兴奋，非常令人兴奋，
and loads to look forward to. But let's start with our protagonist. So this is the man whose voice we heard at the beginning of the episode. This is William Cecil. He's the principal, Secretary of State to Queen Elizabeth I. And he is unquestionably the most powerful man in England at this point, isn't he? He absolutely is. So we have met him before in the series we did on the young Elizabeth, but those you haven't listened to that, who've forgotten it, just to remind ourselves who he is, what he's lived through, what he's about. So he's from a relatively humble background of Welsh extraction, so a little bit of Welsh history again.
有很多值得期待的内容。但让我们从我们的主角开始。这就是我们在剧集开头听到的那个声音。这就是威廉·塞西尔。他是伊丽莎白一世女王的首席国务大臣。毫无疑问，他是此时英国最有权势的人，不是吗？他绝对是。所以我们在关于年轻伊丽莎白的系列节目中见过他，但对于那些没有听过那个系列，或者已经忘记的人，只是提醒一下他是谁，他经历了什么，他是什么样的人。他来自一个相对卑微的威尔士背景，所以又有一点威尔士历史。
Great to us in Welsh history. Yeah, of course. He's from Lincolnshire. He's a very committed Protestant, but even more than that, the thing about him is he's unbelievably alien. I would say perhaps the ablest minister in the whole of British history. And as you said, under Elizabeth I first, he's definitely the most powerful figure in the kingdom. And that is because he has all kinds of qualities.
对威尔士历史很棒。是的，当然。他来自林肯郡。他是一位非常坚定的新教徒，但不仅如此，关于他的一点是，他极其能干。我会说他可能是英国历史上最有能力的大臣。正如你所说，在伊丽莎白一世统治下，他绝对是王国中最有权势的人物。这是因为他具备各种素质。
He's very loyal. He's very subtle. He has an insane capacity for hard work. And basically, he's the master of all the arts of statecraft. And he's also very experienced. So in 1569, he is 49 years old. And by this point, he has served three Tudem monarchs in succession. And these are the three children of his.
他非常忠诚。他非常敏锐。他有疯狂的工作能力。基本上，他是所有治国艺术的大师。而且他非常有经验。所以1569年，他49岁。到这个时候，他已经连续服务了三位都铎王朝的君主。而这三位是他的孩子。
Henry the 8th. The son was Edward the 6th, and he had come to the throne as a young boy in 1547, I mean, very young. But he was a very ardent Protestant. You know, if there were kind of churches to be painted, white and rude screens to be smashed, he'd be piling it. He loved a whitewash. He loved a whitewash. And this is great for Cecil, who, as we said, is an ardent Protestant. So to be very able and to be an ardent Protestant under Edward VIII was great. And so Cecil, the Tudor Board of Snakes and Ladders, he is shooting up those ladders under Edward the 6th. But then in 1553, total disaster for Cecil
亨利八世。儿子是爱德华六世，他在1547年以一个小男孩的身份登上王位，我的意思是，非常年轻。但他是一位非常热心的新教徒。你知道，如果有教堂需要粉刷，圣坛屏需要砸碎，他都会冲在前面。他喜欢粉刷。他喜欢粉刷。这对塞西尔来说太棒了，正如我们所说，他是一位热心的新教徒。所以能在爱德华六世统治下表现得非常有能力且是一位热心的新教徒真是太好了。所以塞西尔，在都铎王朝的“蛇与梯子”游戏中，他在爱德华六世统治下迅速攀升。但随后在1553年，对塞西尔来说是彻底的灾难，
because Edward dies at the very tender age of 15. And he is succeeded by his elder sister, Mary. And when I say elder, I mean, she's really elder because she's 37 at that point. And she is the daughter of Henry VIII's first wife, Catherine of Aragon, who is both very Catholic and very Spanish. and Mary has inherited a fondness for Catholicism and the Spanish that will result in England kind of doing a massive reverse turn from Edward's Protestant settlement. So Mary returns England to papal obedience.
因为爱德华在15岁的花样年华去世了。继位的是他的姐姐玛丽。当我说是姐姐时，我的意思是，她确实是姐姐，因为她当时已经37岁了。她是亨利八世的第一任妻子阿拉贡的凯瑟琳的女儿，她既非常天主教又非常西班牙化。玛丽继承了对天主教和西班牙人的喜爱，这将导致英格兰从爱德华的新教定居点进行大规模的逆转。所以玛丽让英格兰回归了教皇的顺从。
She marries a very, very Catholic husband, and this is Philip of Spain, who is the heir to an enormous empire, so not just Spain itself, but the low countries, huge chunks of Italy, great sways of the new world. So all those lands that the conquistadors have conquered. But what about Cecil during this period? Because presumably he, as an ultra-protestant, yeah, this is not good for him. Yeah, so we said he's subtle. I mean, his subtlety at this point consisting very much in keeping his head down.
她嫁给了一位非常、非常天主教的丈夫，这就是西班牙的菲利普，他是庞大帝国的继承人，所以不仅仅是西班牙本身，还有低地国家，意大利的大片地区，新世界的大片领土。所以所有那些征服者征服的土地。但塞西尔在这期间怎么样了？因为大概他，作为一个极端新教徒，是的，这对他是没有好处的。是的，所以我们说他很敏锐。我的意思是，他此时的敏锐主要在于保持低调。
But also kind of looking around and thinking, well, what if Mary doesn't survive? What if she doesn't have a child, which he ends up not doing? Who will then the air be? And the answer is it will be this very Protestant half-sister of Mary called Elizabeth. And Mary hates and fears Elizabeth for reasons that go a very long way back, because we said, Catherine Varaghan, this Catholic Spanish princess, who is Mary's mother, Henry's first wife, had notoriously been divorced and dumped by Henry VIII in favor of Amber Lynn, who was Protestant. And Ambelin was Elizabeth's mother.
但也环顾四周思考，嗯，如果玛丽没有活下来怎么办？如果她没有孩子，而她最终确实没有。那么继承人会是谁？答案是玛丽那个非常新教的同父异母妹妹，叫伊丽莎白。玛丽憎恨并恐惧伊丽莎白，原因可以追溯到很久以前，因为我们说过，阿拉贡的凯瑟琳，这位天主教西班牙公主，是玛丽的母亲，亨利的第一任妻子，曾因安妮·博林（她是新教徒）而臭名昭著地被亨利八世离婚并抛弃。而安妮·博林是伊丽莎白的母亲。
So as Elizabeth grows up, Mary's supporters and Catholics more generally see Elizabeth as this kind of bastard daughter of a heretic, a witch, a whore, this woman who had been executed in the Tower of London. And so Elizabeth is the great kind of bogey for Catholics, but that of course makes her the great prospect, the great heroine for Protestants like Cecil. For large stretches of Mary's reign, Elizabeth has kept pretty isolated, either actually in the tower for several months or kind of in the depths of the countryside. But Cecil, he is kind of putting out feel as to Elizabeth and kind of serving really as her kind of right-hand man, her teacher, her instructor in the arts of statecraft. Her conigiary. Yes. And so by 1558, it is becoming clear that not only is Mary not going to have a child, but that she is dying. So then on the 17th November 1558, the long awaited moment comes.
所以随着伊丽莎白长大，玛丽的支持者和天主教徒更普遍地将伊丽莎白视为一个异教徒、女巫、妓女的私生女，这个女人曾在伦敦塔被处决。所以伊丽莎白是天主教徒眼中的大魔头，但这当然使她成为像塞西尔这样的新教徒眼中的伟大希望，伟大的女英雄。在玛丽统治的大部分时间里，伊丽莎白一直保持相当孤立，要么实际上在塔里待了几个月，要么在乡村深处。但塞西尔，他一直在向伊丽莎白试探，并真正担任她的得力助手，她的老师，她在治国艺术方面的指导者。她的顾问。是的。所以到了1558年，情况变得很清楚，玛丽不仅不会有孩子，而且她快要死了。于是1558年11月17日，期待已久的时刻到来了。
Mary does die. Elizabeth becomes queen. She's 25 years old. And as everybody expects, her new chief secretary is William Cecil. And his priority is to have a new U-turn after Mary's U-turn to turn back to what he regards as the faith into lead England into the sunlit uplands of Protestantism. And he has a fair bit of leeway to do this because Elizabeth basically is placing a colossal amount of trust in him. I mean, he's got a lot of power, hasn't he? Yeah. So Elizabeth says to him, I want you as minister to do
玛丽去世了。伊丽莎白成为女王。她25岁。正如每个人所预料的那样，她的新首席秘书是威廉·塞西尔。他的首要任务是在玛丽的U型转弯之后进行新的U型转弯，回归他所认为的信仰，将英格兰带入新教的阳光高地。他有相当大的余地来做这件事，因为伊丽莎白基本上对他寄予了巨大的信任。我的意思是，他拥有很大的权力，不是吗？是的。所以伊丽莎白对他说，我希望你作为大臣去做
what you think is right for me in the country, even if I may not necessarily agree with you. So that is an incredible degree of trust. The kind of contrast with her father, of course, he was very prone to shopping the heads of ministers with whom he ended up disagreeing. Elizabeth is saying, I won't do this and she stays true to that word. Do you think she does that partly because she's a woman? Do you think she feels that she needs a reliable, stable chief minister? She can't go through them as her father did. I think that's part of it, but I think it's more the case that Elizabeth has a very, very astute eye for talent and she can recognize what she has in Cecil. And maybe the measure of that is that normally a king or queen is served by various secretaries, but Cecil is her only secretary.
你认为什么是对我有益的，即使我未必完全同意你的观点。这是一种极高的信任。这与她父亲形成了鲜明的对比，当然，她父亲非常倾向于砍掉那些最终与他意见不合的大臣的脑袋。伊丽莎白说，我不会这样做，并且她信守了诺言。你认为她这样做部分是因为她是女性吗？你认为她觉得她需要一位可靠、稳定的首席大臣吗？她不能像她父亲那样频繁更换大臣。我认为这是原因之一，但我认为更主要的原因是伊丽莎白对人才有着非常敏锐的眼光，她能识别出塞西尔的价值。也许衡量这一点的标准是，通常国王或女王由多位秘书服务，但塞西尔是她唯一的秘书。
And effectively, I said he's the ablest man in the history of English government. I mean, he's definitely the most tireless. So to quote Stephen Orford, who's written the definitive biography of Cecil, by design and by instinct, he was at the heart of Elizabeth's court. He controlled the machinery of power. He ran the royal secretariat and chaired meetings to the Privy Council. He advised the Queen daily and read every piece of paper that was sent to her. He was Elizabeth's voice to the world for he wrote her letters and proclamations
实际上，我说过他是英国政府史上最有能力的人。我的意思是，他绝对是最不知疲倦的。引用斯蒂芬·奥福德的话，他撰写了塞西尔的权威传记，出于设计和本能，他处于伊丽莎白宫廷的核心。他控制着权力机器。他管理着皇家秘书处并主持枢密院会议。他每天为女王提供建议，并阅读送给她的每一份文件。他是伊丽莎白向世界发出的声音，因为他撰写了她的信件和公告
and drafted the instructions to her ambassadors. With ready access to her in her private rooms and a mastery of the government machine, he saw and heard all that went on at court. So he has a finger in every pie going. So some people might be reminded of, especially people who've read Wolf Hall and the successor books might be reminded of Thomas Cromwell, who was another very mighty chief minister. but I suppose the difference is that Thomas Cromwell, who was Henry the eighth's chief minister,
并起草了给她大使的指示。由于可以随时进入她的私人房间并掌握了政府机器，他看到并听到了宫廷里发生的一切。所以他无所不知。有些人可能会想起，特别是那些读过《狼厅》及其续集的人，可能会想起托马斯·克伦威尔，他是另一位非常有权势的首席大臣。但我认为区别在于托马斯·克伦威尔，亨利八世的首席大臣，
was a bit of a blunt instrument, wasn't he? Whereas Cessor operates more cleverly in the shadows, he's smoother, I suppose. I think also Cromwell was loyal to Henry, but not sufficiently loyal in the end, whereas Cessel is always loyal. And even when he is going against what seems to be Elizabeth's wishes, Elizabeth is confident that he is ultimately serving her purposes and her cause, And she never doubts that. And I think she's right not to doubt that.
是一个比较迟钝的工具，不是吗？而塞西尔在阴影中运作得更巧妙，我想他更圆滑。我认为克伦威尔对亨利忠诚，但最终不够忠诚，而塞西尔始终忠诚。即使当他违背伊丽莎白的意愿时，伊丽莎白也相信他最终是在为她的目的和事业服务，她从不怀疑这一点。我认为她不怀疑他是对的。
And the reason that Cecil is loyal to Elizabeth isn't just a personal loyalty. It's a conviction that God has placed her on the throne to serve as a kind of a Deborah, a judge sent to rule God's chosen people and to help kind of bring them out of the bondage of popery and superstition. But also what steals him in his sense of mission, I think, is a sense that within England, Protestants are. surrounded by enemies and that within Europe, England is surrounded by enemies and that these enemies are working to destroy England's path to godliness. And that therefore, although it may not be an open war, it is a cold war in which falsehood is attempting to overthrow truth and hell is raging against the forces of heaven and Satan against Christ. And I think that unless you accept that this is fundamental to Cecil's vision and purpose. You don't really understand what is at stake in Elizabethan
塞西尔对伊丽莎白的忠诚不仅仅是个人忠诚。这是一种信念，认为上帝将她置于王位上，是为了让她成为某种底波拉，一位被派来统治上帝选民的法官，并帮助他们摆脱教皇制度和迷信的束缚。但我也认为，坚定他使命感的是一种感觉，即在英格兰内部，新教徒被敌人包围；在欧洲内部，英格兰被敌人包围，这些敌人正致力于摧毁英格兰通往神圣的道路。因此，虽然这可能不是一场公开的战争，但这是一场冷战，谎言试图推翻真理，地狱在向天堂的力量咆哮，撒旦在向基督咆哮。我认为，除非你接受这是塞西尔愿景和目的的基础，否则你真的无法理解伊丽莎白时代在这一时期面临的利害关系。
England in this period. It is fundamental to the way that Cecil sees the world. So he's simultaneously a man of subtlety and nuance, but also a man who at his heart believes this is ultimately a straightforward clash between right and wrong, truth and lies, you know, the way of heaven and the way of hell, I guess. So we started, and we were 10 years on, effectively, more than a decade on, from Elizabeth's coronation. And when Cecil wrote that briefing paper, I mean, he doesn't say, well, 10 years on and everything is great. He actually, there is a sense of sort of existential urgency to his briefing, because he thinks that Elizabeth is more in battle than ever before. And this comes back to the issue of her great rival, doesn't it, Mary Queen of Scots?
英格兰在这一时期。这是塞西尔看待世界的基础。所以他既是一个微妙而细致的人，同时也是一个内心深处相信这最终是正义与邪恶、真理与谎言、天堂之路与地狱之路之间直接冲突的人。所以我们开始时，实际上距离伊丽莎白加冕已经过去了10年，超过十年了。当塞西尔写那份简报时，他并没有说，好吧，10年过去了，一切都很棒。实际上，他的简报中有一种存在主义的紧迫感，因为他认为伊丽莎白比以往任何时候都更处于战斗状态。这又回到了她最大的竞争对手的问题上，不是吗，苏格兰女王玛丽？
I mean, if you read that briefing paper, which is very detailed and fascinating, he doesn't quite put it in these terms. But essentially, Cecil sees all of England's problems as stemming from two women. And the first of these two women is actually the queen herself, Cecil's royal mistress, Elizabeth Tudor. We've said Cecil is devoted to her, but he also finds her completely infuriating. He finds her willful, mercurial, obstinate in all kinds of matters in which he thinks she should not be obstinate. And her absolute worst mistake in Cecil's opinion is to cling to a policy that she is held to right from her coronation. And Cecil describes it as being her coldness and forbearing from the beginning of her reign to proceed in marriage. Just to play devil's advocate.
我的意思是，如果你读那份非常详细且引人入胜的简报，他并没有完全用这些词来表达。但本质上，塞西尔认为英格兰的所有问题都源于两个女人。这两个女人中的第一个实际上是女王本人，塞西尔的皇家女主人，伊丽莎白·都铎。我们说过塞西尔对她很忠诚，但他同时也觉得她非常令人恼火。他发现她任性、反复无常、固执，在各种他认为她不应该固执的事情上。在塞西尔看来，她最严重的错误是坚持一种她从加冕时就一直坚持的政策。塞西尔将其描述为她从统治之初就表现出的冷漠和不愿结婚。为了反驳一下。
She has refused to marry for actually very good reasons. talked about them in our previous series about the young Elizabeth. Because once you marry, you hand over your autonomy and your power, don't you as a queen? And you hand all of that over to your husband. And she just doesn't want to make that mistake. Well, there's the example of Mary Tudor who had married Philip of Spain. And lots of Englishmen, not necessarily Protestants, felt that this had subordinated England to Spain's interests. And Elizabeth doesn't want to repeat that mistake. And as you say, she absolutely has very good politic reasons for remaining a virgin. And in the way, it's amazing that Cecil can't see this. And also, I think, what's surprising,
她拒绝结婚其实是有非常好的理由的。我们在关于年轻伊丽莎白的上一系列节目中谈到过。因为一旦结婚，你就交出了你的自主权和权力，不是吗，作为女王？你把这一切都交给了你的丈夫。她只是不想犯那个错误。好吧，有玛丽·都铎嫁给西班牙菲利普的例子。许多英国人，不一定是新教徒，觉得这使英格兰从属于西班牙的利益。伊丽莎白不想重蹈覆辙。正如你所说，她绝对有非常好的政治理由保持童贞。在某种程度上，令人惊讶的是塞西尔看不出这一点。而且，我认为，令人惊讶的是，
considering how astute Cecil is, that he doesn't recognize how brilliant a diplomatic weapon it is, that Elizabeth's virginity means that she has something to offer all kinds of people, and she can play them along and, you know, play hard to get and kind of dangle the prospect of of kind of teaming up with a suitor. And it enables her to play France and Spain off against each other. But to play Devils Avica on the other side, Cecil actually has a good point about not marrying. Because, of course, this is a very high risk strategy.
考虑到塞西尔是多么精明，他没有意识到这是一个多么出色的外交武器，伊丽莎白的童贞意味着她可以向各种人提供一些东西，她可以敷衍他们，你知道，欲擒故纵，并悬挂与求婚者联手的希望。这使她能够让法国和西班牙相互对抗。但从反面来看，塞西尔关于不结婚的观点其实很有道理。因为，当然，这是一个风险极高的策略。
This is an age when, you know, you can get flu or you can get dysentery or whatever. And you're, and that's it, you're gone. And if she dies, everything that he's building will have been for nothing. And you said, you know, Elizabeth might fall ill. So in 1562, she caught smallpox and very nearly died of it. And of course, Cecil and all Elizabeth's ministers are agonizingly aware of the fact that there are foreign agents and there are domestic traitors out there who know that all they have to do is slip us and poison or, you know, bring out, take out a dagger or even a pistol. You know, this is an era where assassins are starting to think, well, we could shoot ahead of state. So the jeopardy is enormous.
这是一个你可能会得流感、痢疾或其他什么的时代。然后，就这样，你就完了。如果她死了，他所建立的一切都将付诸东流。你说过，伊丽莎白可能会生病。所以在1562年，她患了天花，差点死掉。当然，塞西尔和伊丽莎白所有的部长们都痛苦地意识到，外面有外国特工和国内叛徒，他们知道他们所要做的就是下毒，或者拿出匕首，甚至是一把手枪。你知道，这是一个刺客开始认为，好吧，我们可以射杀国家元首的时代。所以危险是巨大的。
And again, I think this is something that listeners have to bear in mind. We know that Elizabeth survives to a ripe old age. You know, she has this incredibly lengthy reign. But that jeopardy is there throughout the rain, and particularly in this period, Elizabeth is very vulnerable, and that means that Protestant England is very vulnerable. because if Elizabeth dies or is killed, then from Cecil's perspective, this will spell the triumph of Antichrist
同样，我认为这是听众必须记住的一点。我们知道伊丽莎白活到了高龄。你知道，她有着极其漫长的统治期。但这种危险在整个统治期间都存在，特别是在这一时期，伊丽莎白非常脆弱，这意味着新教英格兰非常脆弱。因为如果伊丽莎白死了或被杀，那么从塞西尔的角度来看，这将意味着敌基督的胜利
because Elizabeth's obvious air of, as we've said, is the second woman to haunt his nightmares. And this is Mary Stewart, the Queen of Scots. So we did a whole series about Mary Queen of Scots last year, didn't we? And we were talking, I mean, we talked in that series. She's Elizabeth's cousin. She has chewed up blood in her veins, so she's not just a Stuart.
因为正如我们所说，伊丽莎白显而易见的继承人是第二个困扰他噩梦的女人。这就是苏格兰女王玛丽·斯图亚特。所以我们去年做了一个关于苏格兰女王玛丽的完整系列，不是吗？我们在那个系列中谈到了。她是伊丽莎白的表亲。她血管里流着都铎的血，所以她不仅仅是斯图亚特家族的人。
She has Tudor blood. She is a Catholic, and she's actually one of the worst kinds of Catholics, you can find, because she is... She's a French Catholic, basically. So her mother was from the great Catholic aristocratic dynasty, the Gies dynasty. Yeah. But she'd also been brought up effectively as a French woman, as a French princess, and she had briefly been the Queen of France. Yes. So I don't think any patriotic Englishman wants a queen like that on the throne.
她有都铎的血统。她是天主教徒，而且她实际上是你所能找到的最糟糕的天主教徒之一，因为她是……她基本上是法国天主教徒。所以她的母亲来自伟大的天主教贵族王朝，吉斯王朝。是的。但她也被有效地培养成了一个法国女人，一个法国公主，并且曾短暂地担任过法国女王。是的。所以我认为没有一个爱国的英国人希望这样的女王坐在王位上。
And not least because you mentioned the Gis. So the Gis, I mean, they're not just the most powerful aristocratic dynasty in France. As we will be seeing in the second half, they are militantly Catholic. And so therefore massive dangers and threats to English Protestantism. So they are really worth bearing in mind that Mary is very closely linked to them. The chief of the Gies was her uncle. This is really bad news for English Protestants. on top of that they see her as a morally evil person as someone who is supposed to have killed her own husband lord darnley who listeners may remember was described as the great cock chick kind of terrible man we actually concluded that mary probably didn't kill him but there was a kind of insane murder plot that involved explosions and people being found in gardens and chairs and all kinds of mad stuff but definitely
尤其是因为你提到了吉斯家族。所以吉斯家族，我的意思是，他们不仅是法国最强大的贵族王朝。正如我们将在下半部分看到的那样，他们是激进的天主教徒。因此，他们对英国新教构成了巨大的危险和威胁。所以他们确实值得记住，玛丽与他们联系非常紧密。吉斯家族的首领是她的叔叔。这对英国新教徒来说真是个坏消息。最重要的是，他们认为她是一个道德败坏的人，是一个据称杀害了自己丈夫达恩利勋爵的人，听众可能还记得他被描述为那个可怕的男人。我们实际上得出结论，玛丽可能没有杀他，但有一个疯狂的谋杀阴谋，涉及爆炸，人们在花园和椅子里被发现，以及各种疯狂的事情，但绝对
In Scotland, as well as in England, people do think that Mary was responsible for killing her husband. And in summer 1567, the Protestant establishment in Scotland had decided that they'd had enough, and they'd risen in rebellion. They defeated Mary in battle. They'd imprisoned her on an island, on a lonely loch, and they had forced her to abdicate. Now, Mary is kind of irrepressible. She's always bouncing back from seemingly total disaster. And on the 2nd of May 1568, she'd managed to escape from this kind of keep on this lonely island. And she set about trying to win her throne.
在苏格兰和英格兰，人们确实认为玛丽应对杀害她丈夫负责。1567年夏天，苏格兰的新教机构决定他们受够了，他们发动了叛乱。他们在战斗中击败了玛丽。他们把她关在岛上，在一个孤独的湖泊上，并强迫她退位。现在，玛丽有点不可抑制。她总是从看似彻底的灾难中反弹。1568年5月2日，她设法从这个孤独岛屿上的堡垒中逃脱。她开始试图夺回她的王位。
But the attempt had been a disaster. She'd lost a battle. And so she had decided, what can I do now? The only thing I can really do is to go to England and ask my cousin Elizabeth for help. And so on the 16th of May, she had left Scotland forever from this very romantic spot below Dundrennan Abbey. in Galway, very eerie place. I went and visited it at the New Year. And she gets into a fishing boat and she rose across the Solway Firth to Cumbria in England, Westmoreland as it was. And she steps foot onto English soil and she immediately writes first to Elizabeth to explain,
但这次尝试是一场灾难。她输掉了一场战斗。所以她决定，我现在能做什么？我唯一能做的就是去英格兰，请求我的表亲伊丽莎白帮助。于是5月16日，她永远离开了苏格兰，从邓德雷南修道院下方那个非常浪漫的地方。在加洛韦，一个非常阴森的地方。我在新年去参观过它。她坐上一艘渔船，划过索尔韦湾到达英格兰的坎布里亚，也就是当时的威斯特摩兰。她踏上了英格兰的土地，并立即写信给伊丽莎白解释，
you know, what she's hoping for. And then madly to Cecil. And she said, I have the hope of obtaining the assistance of your good counsel. And that is mad because of course Cecil is her deadliest enemy. Sessel hates her. In fact, you know, he wants her dead. Let's be absolutely blunt. That is Sessel's endgame. He wants her removed from the chessboard. While Mary had been Queen of Scots on the throne in Scotland, this Catholic, this Gies, this essentially French woman, she had been haunting Cecil's nightmares. Now she's come to England. She is still a threat, but at least she is now kind of under lock and key, because Cecil, does not allow Elizabeth to help her.
你知道，她希望得到什么。然后疯狂地写信给塞西尔。她说，我希望得到你良好建议的帮助。这很疯狂，因为塞西尔当然是她最致命的敌人。塞西尔恨她。事实上，你知道，他想让她死。让我们直截了当地说。这就是塞西尔的终局。他想把她从棋盘上移走。当玛丽在苏格兰王位上担任苏格兰女王时，这个天主教徒，这个吉斯家族的人，这个本质上的法国女人，一直困扰着塞西尔的噩梦。现在她来到了英格兰。她仍然是一个威胁，但至少她现在被锁起来了，因为塞西尔不允许伊丽莎白帮助她。
And in fact, Elizabeth is happy not to help her. So instead, she's placed under this kind of house arrest. And Cecil is hoping that Elizabeth can be persuaded to license her execution. But there is a problem because although Elizabeth has no fondness for Mary, and although she entirely recognises the danger that Mary as a Catholic represents to the future of Protestant England, The salient thing from Elizabeth's point of view, even more important than Mary's Catholicism, is the fact that she is an anointed monarch. And you cannot, from Elizabeth's point of view, simply chop off the head of an anointed monarch. Because Elizabeth herself is an anointed monarch and she does not want to be the queen who established the precedent that said it was okay to execute anointed monarch.
事实上，伊丽莎白很高兴不帮助她。所以相反，她被软禁了。塞西尔希望伊丽莎白能被说服批准处决她。但有一个问题，因为虽然伊丽莎白对玛丽没有好感，虽然她完全认识到玛丽作为天主教徒对新教英格兰未来的危险，但从伊丽莎白的观点来看，比玛丽的天主教信仰更重要的是，她是一位受膏的君主。从伊丽莎白的观点来看，你不能简单地砍掉一位受膏君主的头。因为伊丽莎白本人也是一位受膏君主，她不想成为那个确立了处决受膏君主先例的女王。
ruler. This is the problem. This is the dilemma that is confronting Elizabeth and Cecil. What are they going to do with Mary Queen of Scots and how are they possibly going to bolster this Protestant regime? We will find out after the break. This episode is brought to you by National Geographic. Tom, we're familiar, aren't we, with what happened in Pompeii when Vesuvius exploded. We absolutely are. So, AD 79, Vesuvius blows its top. Debris rains down on Pompeii. It ends with a pyroclastic flow, which essentially entombs the city, entombs everyone left living there, and it lay there waiting to be brought to light
统治者。这就是问题所在。这就是伊丽莎白和塞西尔面临的困境。他们要如何处理苏格兰女王玛丽，他们又将如何巩固这个新教政权？休息后我们将揭晓。本集由国家地理频道为您呈现。汤姆，我们很熟悉维苏威火山爆发时庞贝发生的事情，对吧？我们当然熟悉。所以，公元79年，维苏威火山爆发。碎片雨点般落在庞贝城。它以火山碎屑流结束，这基本上掩埋了这座城市，掩埋了所有留在那里活着的人，它就在那里等待着被发掘
centuries and centuries later. Now in Pompeii, out of time with Tom Hiddleston, Hiddleston will guide you between past and present. He will uncover the real story. of the people who lived through one of history's most notorious disasters. It is a cinematic masterpiece from the makers of Loki, and it brings the ancient world vividly to life. Watch Pompeii out of time with Tom Hiddleston,
几个世纪之后。现在在《庞贝：超越时间》中，汤姆·希德勒斯顿将引导你穿越过去和现在。他将揭开真实的故事。那些经历过历史上最臭名昭著灾难之一的人们的故事。这是来自《洛基》制作团队的电影杰作，它生动地再现了古代世界。观看《庞贝：超越时间》与汤姆·希德勒斯顿，
Thursday at 8pm on National Geographic. This episode is brought to you by Hamilton the Musical. Tom, when we think of America's founding fathers, we think of dusty portraits, grim-faced men with terrible teeth, and of course, unpaid tax bills, don't we? That's right, but what we don't see is the struggle, the resentment, the euphoria, the love, the rapping, all in the name of American Independence 250 years ago. That's what we loved, isn't it, about Lynn Manuel Miranda's award-winning musical Hamilton, which we went to see with our team just the other day.
周四晚上8点在国家地理频道。本集由音乐剧《汉密尔顿》为您呈现。汤姆，当我们想到美国的开国元勋时，我们会想到尘土飞扬的肖像，表情严峻、牙齿糟糕的男人，当然还有未付的税单，对吧？没错，但我们没有看到的是斗争、怨恨、欣快、爱、说唱，所有这些都是为了250年前的美国独立。这就是我们所爱的，不是吗，关于林-曼努埃尔·米兰达获奖音乐剧《汉密尔顿》，我们前几天和我们的团队一起去看了。
It brought the story of those turbulent years to life beyond the walls of a museum from the room where. it happened. It's an incredible depiction of the life and legacy of Alexander Hamilton, who was George Washington's right-hand man, an incredibly politically significant figure. It is an absolute cultural phenomenon and you can experience it right now at London's Victoria Palace Theatre. Book tickets today at Hamilton Musical.com forward slash London. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers. The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. What if your immune system could learn to recognize cancer cells?
它让那些动荡岁月的历史故事在博物馆的墙壁之外鲜活起来，从它发生的地方。这是对亚历山大·汉密尔顿生活和遗产的不可思议的描绘，他是乔治·华盛顿的得力助手，是一个在政治上极其重要的人物。这是一个绝对的文化现象，你现在可以在伦敦维多利亚宫剧院体验它。今天就在 HamiltonMusical.com/London 预订门票。嘿，这是来自 Gollhangers 的迈克尔和汉娜。《科学的其余部分》。本集由英国癌症研究中心为您呈现。如果你的免疫系统能学会识别癌细胞会怎样？
That's immunotherapy. One type is car T cell therapy. T cells are your body's watchmen, and doctors can now extract these and reprogram them to spot cancer. CAR T cells, they've started showing this real promise in treating cancers of the blood like leukemia, because unlike most cancers, blood cancer cells, they float around separately,
这就是免疫疗法。其中一种是 CAR-T 细胞疗法。T 细胞是你身体的守望者，医生现在可以提取这些细胞并重新编程，以发现癌症。CAR-T 细胞，它们已经开始在治疗白血病等血液癌症方面显示出真正的希望，因为与大多数癌症不同，血液癌细胞是单独漂浮的，
and that makes it easier for car T cells to see. them out and destroy them. And now, Cancer Research UK-funded scientists are designing CAR-T cells that can tackle solid tumors too, making them tougher so they can survive a more crowded and hostile cancer environment. Now, these approaches are experimental, but they do start to show where treatment might go next. And over the past 50 years, Cancer Research UK's pioneering work has helped to double cancer
这使得 CAR-T 细胞更容易发现它们并摧毁它们。现在，英国癌症研究中心资助的科学家们正在设计能够应对实体瘤的 CAR-T 细胞，使它们更强韧，以便它们能在更拥挤和敌对的癌症环境中生存。现在，这些方法是实验性的，但它们确实开始显示出治疗的未来方向。在过去的50年里，英国癌症研究中心的开创性工作帮助癌症翻了一番
survival in the UK. I mean, this shows you how far research can take us. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research, breakthroughs, and how you can support them, visit cancerresearchuk.org forward slash rest is science. The Hulu original series Furious is coming to Disney Plus, starring Emmy Rossum. Furious follows FBI agent Alice Black on the hunt for a mysterious and calculating serial killer. Both walk their own paths toward justice, and as their lives start to intertwine, the line between right and wrong. begins to blur. Don't miss the three-episode premiere of the Hulu original series Furious on July 27th, only on Hulu on Disney Plus.
在英国的生存。我的意思是，这向你展示了研究能带我们走多远。欲了解更多关于英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究、突破以及你如何支持他们的信息，请访问 cancerresearchuk.org 斜杠 rest is science。Hulu 原创剧集《Furious》即将登陆 Disney Plus，由艾米·罗森主演。该剧讲述了联邦调查局探员爱丽丝·布莱克追捕一名神秘而工于心计的连环杀手的故事。两人都走在各自的正义之路上，随着他们的生活开始交织，对与错的界限开始变得模糊。千万不要错过 7 月 27 日在 Disney Plus 上的 Hulu 原创剧集《Furious》的三集首播。
Welcome back to The Rest is History. So we are in the autumn of 1569 and we are in Westminster on the Strand. Specifically, we are in Cecil House. So this is the family home of the the man we were talking about in the first half, William Cecil, the chief minister of Elizabeth I, but this is also the headquarters, the nerve centre of his entire operation. So the house has just been finished. Cecil helped design it. It's got orchards. It's got nice symmetrical gardens. It's got a kind of tennis court. It's got a bowling alley. He's got his study looking out over the garden where he can look out and he can contemplate his schemes. His study is full of books and coins and antiquities and things.
欢迎回到《历史的余味》。现在是 1569 年的秋天，我们身处河岸街的威斯敏斯特。具体来说，我们是在塞西尔府。这是我们上半场谈到的那个人——伊丽莎白一世的首席大臣威廉·塞西尔的家庭住宅，但这里也是他整个行动的总部和神经中枢。这座房子刚刚完工，塞西尔参与了设计。它有果园，有对称的漂亮花园，还有一个网球场和一个保龄球馆。他的书房可以俯瞰花园，在那里他可以沉思他的计划。他的书房里摆满了书籍、硬币、古董和各种物件。
And in this world, he is contemplating the problems of protecting his patron, Elizabeth I and ensuring the survival of her regime at the apex of Protestant England. Because when he looks out at the world, Dom, he sees it as a play. I mean, we see Elizabeth in England as this kind of, you know, golden world of people slapping their thighs and exchanging Shakespearean banter. but he sees it as a world of danger and plots and traitors and conspiracies, doesn't he? So we've talked about how there are kind of echoes of contemporary spy thrillers in this 16th century story. And people who've seen slow horses, the name comes from Slough House, which is this kind of terrible metaphor for the state of Britain,
在这个世界里，他正在思考如何保护他的赞助人伊丽莎白一世，并确保她的政权在英格兰新教徒的巅峰时期得以生存。因为当他望向世界时，多姆，他将其视为一场戏。我的意思是，我们把伊丽莎白时代的英格兰看作是一个金色的世界，人们拍着大腿，交流着莎士比亚式的俏皮话，但他看到的却是一个充满危险、阴谋、叛徒和诡计的世界，不是吗？所以我们谈到了这个 16 世纪的故事中如何带有当代间谍惊悚片的影子。看过《流人》的人都知道，这个名字来源于“流人屋”（Slough House），这是对英国现状的一种可怕的隐喻，
crumbling decay, decrepit place where failed spies live. I think that Cecil House has a similar metaphorical quality, but it is a very, much more impressive. So you've described how, you know, it's, it's exquisite, it's beautiful, it's ordered, and it's this great nerve centre in which Cecil's mighty political brain is kind of pulsing like a beacon. But beyond the walls, the very thick walls of Cecil House, you have seething alleyways, you have kind of squalid tenement blocks, they're rife with violence, heavy with plague and then of course beyond them as you said there are even more dangers so that sense of Cecil's world as a kind of still centre from which he can try to dampen down all the
一个摇摇欲坠、破败不堪、失败间谍居住的地方。我认为塞西尔府也有类似的隐喻色彩，但它要宏伟得多。你描述了它是多么精致、美丽、有序，它是塞西尔强大的政治大脑像灯塔一样跳动的伟大神经中枢。但在塞西尔府那厚厚的围墙之外，是沸腾的小巷，是肮脏的廉租房，那里充斥着暴力，笼罩着瘟疫，当然，正如你所说，在那之外还有更多的危险。因此，塞西尔的世界被视为一个静止的中心，他可以从中试图平息所有
dangers and the perils that are threatening Protestant England I think it's a kind of very powerful sense I think he had it I think that's why it mattered to him that Cecil house was a place of order. It's a counterpoint to the chaos that he feels that he is combating. And, you know, there is no question what the greatest danger facing England is as Cecil sees it. So in the short memorial of the state of the realm, which you began the episode with a reading from, he'd drawn up all these kind of dangers, but he said that ultimately they all go back to the one poisonous focus, and that is Mary Queen of Scots, Mary Stewart. And he sums it up, the exulting of the Queen of Scots, shall please the Pope. The two monarchies of France and Spain, and all the Papists in
威胁着新教英格兰的危险和灾难，我认为这是一种非常有力的感觉。我认为他有这种感觉，这就是为什么塞西尔府作为一个秩序之地对他如此重要。这是对他所感受到的混乱的一种对立。而且，毫无疑问，在塞西尔看来，英格兰面临的最大危险是什么。所以，在他那份《王国状况简短备忘录》（你在这集开头读过）中，他列举了所有这些危险，但他最终说，它们都归结为一个毒源，那就是苏格兰女王玛丽·斯图亚特。他总结道，苏格兰女王的崛起将取悦教皇、法国和西班牙这两个君主国，以及所有基督教世界的教皇党人，包括英格兰和苏格兰。所以到处都是敌人。听众可能想知道，他对此判断正确吗？是否真的存在一个涵盖英格兰和苏格兰天主教徒的巨大阴谋，也就是你可能称之为“内部敌人”的东西？但还有西班牙国王腓力二世、法国国王和教皇。如果存在阴谋，其目的是推翻伊丽莎白女王吗？阴谋者是否想用苏格兰女王玛丽取代伊丽莎白？那么，玛丽·斯图亚特真的是塞西尔认为的那种危险吗？好吧，让我们从英格兰开始。
Christendom, England and Scotland. So there are enemies everywhere. And so listeners may be wondering, well, is he right about this? Is there actually a vast conspiracy that embraces Catholics in England and Scotland, the kind of enemy within you might want to call? But also Philip the second of Spain, the King of France and the Pope. And if there is a conspiracy, is its aim to topple Queen Elizabeth, and are the conspirators looking to replace Elizabeth with Mary Queen of Scott? So is Mary Stewart really the danger that Cecil thinks that she is? Well, let's start with England.
（注：原文索引52与53内容重叠，此处按原文顺序翻译）
England itself. I mean, you said, oh, you know, people think of it as maples and all of this kind of thing, Elizabethan England. But actually, when Cecil looks, if you can picture him kind of looking at his map or his dashboard or something, the lights are flashing red, there are enemies everywhere on the map. And there's good reason for that because England has been a very troubled place in 1569. Well, more specifically,
英格兰本身。我的意思是，你说过，人们认为它是五朔节花柱之类的东西，伊丽莎白时代的英格兰。但实际上，当塞西尔观察时，如果你能想象他看着他的地图或仪表盘之类的东西，灯光在闪烁红色，地图上到处都是敌人。这是有充分理由的，因为 1569 年的英格兰一直是一个非常动荡的地方。更具体地说，
there's been this terrifying warning that no one can ignore, which is the fact that a servant woman in Leicestershire had given birth to a cat. And everyone has agreed that, well, here we go. Well, here we go. Yeah.
有一个没人能忽视的恐怖警告，那就是莱斯特郡的一名女仆生下了一只猫。每个人都同意，好吧，我们要倒霉了。好吧，我们要倒霉了。是的。
This is very bad. And sure enough, on the 6th of September, 1569, a massive crisis does break out and it's incredibly dangerous because it embroils England's most powerful nobleman. And this is the Duke of Norfolk who comes in person to Elizabeth while she's on one of her kind of grand processions around the country. I think she's actually in Wiltshire at the time. So the Duke of Norfolk comes to the Queen in Wiltshire and he makes this stunning confession. He says, I've actually secretly been negotiating behind your back to marry Mary Queen of Scots. I hope you're all right with that.
这非常糟糕。果然，在 1569 年 9 月 6 日，一场巨大的危机爆发了，而且极其危险，因为它卷入了英格兰最有权势的贵族。这就是诺福克公爵，他亲自来到伊丽莎白身边，当时她正在全国进行某种盛大的巡游。我想她当时实际上是在威尔特郡。所以诺福克公爵来到威尔特郡见女王，他做出了这个惊人的忏悔。他说，我实际上一直在背着你秘密谈判，想娶苏格兰女王玛丽。我希望你对此没意见。
Insane. Elizabeth is absolutely not all right with this because the Duke of Norfolk is her own second cousin. So he has royal blood. So if he marries Mary Queen of Scots, I mean, that is a very, very kind of dangerous combination. He's also incredibly rich. He's by far the wealthiest landowner in the country after Elizabeth herself. And the worst thing of all is that even though he's been raised a Protestant, everyone knows that he's a crypto-Catholic.
疯了。伊丽莎白绝对对此有意见，因为诺福克公爵是她自己的表亲。所以他有皇室血统。如果他娶了苏格兰女王玛丽，那是一个非常、非常危险的组合。他也非常富有。他是除伊丽莎白本人之外全国最富有的地主。最糟糕的是，尽管他被培养成新教徒，但每个人都知道他是一个隐秘的天主教徒。
I mean, I suppose if they all know he's a crypto-Catholic, he's not really Crypto-Catholic. He's hiding in plain sight. Well, everyone knows basically he's Catholic. So he's kind of rich, he's got royal blood, he's Catholic, he's going, he's been kind of negotiating with Mary Queen of Scots to marry her. This is really bad news. And the only reason that he could possibly turn up and tell Elizabeth this and think that
我的意思是，我想如果他们都知道他是隐秘的天主教徒，那他就不算隐秘了。他是在众目睽睽之下隐藏。好吧，每个人基本上都知道他是天主教徒。所以他很有钱，有皇室血统，是天主教徒，而且他一直在和苏格兰女王玛丽谈判要娶她。这真是个坏消息。他唯一可能跑去告诉伊丽莎白并认为
she won't kind of blow a gasket is because he's madly arrogant and obtuse. And yet a member of the aristocracy. I mean, who could possibly have guessed that? There's a certain Andrew Mountbatten, Windsor quality to his political antennae, I think. And so when Elizabeth explodes and she says, what, you know, what are you thinking? What are you, why are you contemplating doing this? He calms her down by saying that when he was in his tennis court at Norwich, he thought himself in a manner equal with some kings.
她不会发火的原因是他极其傲慢和愚钝。然而他还是贵族的一员。我的意思是，谁能猜到呢？我认为他的政治天线有一种安德鲁·蒙巴顿-温莎式的特质。所以当伊丽莎白爆发并说，你到底在想什么？你为什么要考虑这样做？他通过说当他在诺里奇的网球场时，他认为自己某种程度上等同于一些国王，从而让她冷静下来。
So it's fine. I can marry Queen of Scots because, you know, I am basically a king. That's insane. That really is absolutely bonkers. Yeah. So Elizabeth is furious. She kind of tells Norfolk to go back to his estate and stay there. And she puts the militia on full alert across the country.
所以没关系。我可以娶苏格兰女王，因为我基本上就是个国王。这太疯狂了。这确实完全是胡言乱语。是的。所以伊丽莎白很愤怒。她让诺福克回到他的庄园待着。她让全国的民兵进入全面戒备状态。
She closes down the East Anglian ports in case ships full of Spanish sailors are going to be descending on them. And she gives her blessing to Cecil to do what he feels needs to be done. And this is the kind of order that Cecil loves. Yeah. You know, go in hard, rip out the treason and the treachery. And Cecil does go in hard. So on the 1st of October, he has the Duke of Norfolk arrested and placed in the tower. And then in the 6th of October, he has a private meeting with the Queen.
她关闭了东安格利亚的港口，以防满载西班牙水手的船只降临。她祝福塞西尔去做他认为需要做的事情。这就是塞西尔喜欢的秩序。是的。强硬出击，铲除叛乱和背叛。塞西尔确实强硬出击了。所以 10 月 1 日，他逮捕了诺福克公爵并将其关进塔楼。然后在 10 月 6 日，他与女王进行了私人会面。
And again, he goes in hard about Mary Queen of Scots. And he says, the Queen of Scots indeed is and shall always be a dangerous person to your estate. Implication, let's execute her. Elizabeth is not ready to do that. But, you know, she has basically given the green light to Cecil that you can do what you like with the Duke of Norfolk. And so shortly afterwards, Cecil licenses the publication of a pamphlet, which is called Discourse Touching the Pretended Match between the Duke of Norfolk and the Queen of Scots. And this is a kind of classic Cecil manoeuvre. You leak things.
他再次就苏格兰女王玛丽的问题采取了强硬态度。他说，苏格兰女王确实并将永远是你政权的危险人物。言下之意，处决她吧。伊丽莎白还没准备好那样做。但是，她基本上给了塞西尔绿灯，让他可以对诺福克公爵做任何他想做的事。所以不久之后，塞西尔授权出版了一本小册子，名为《关于诺福克公爵与苏格兰女王之间假定婚约的论述》。这是一种典型的塞西尔式策略。你泄露信息。
You kind of hand vital information to people who then kind of smuggle it out without actually acknowledging where it's come from. I mean, again, it's kind of very familiar to contemporary politics, the well-placed leak. And this pamphlet very savagely attacks Norfolk as a papist, says, you know, he's not a Protestant at all, he's a servant of the Pope, he's dangerous and evil, goes in hard against Mary again, condemns her as a competitor of the crown, a thing publicly known, harps on her Frenchness, emphasizes her family connections to the geese, the sinister French noble family, the kind of the arch-Catholics, describes them as a race that is both enemy to God and the common, quiet of Europe and emphasises how Mary is related to them. So this is blackening both Norfolk and Mary and it's clearly serving Cecil's purposes. It's clearly been commissioned by him. And the author of this pamphlet, almost certainly, is a protege of Cecil who is a very sober man, a very subtle man like Cecil, again like Cecil, a very committed Protestant. And this is a man who will be playing a key role in our story. He's a man called Francis Walsingham.
你把重要信息交给那些人，然后他们把信息偷运出去，而不承认来源。我的意思是，这再次与当代政治非常相似，即精心安排的泄密。这本小册子非常猛烈地攻击诺福克是教皇党人，说他根本不是新教徒，他是教皇的仆人，他危险而邪恶，再次猛烈抨击玛丽，谴责她是王位的竞争者，这是一件众所周知的事情，喋喋不休地谈论她的法国血统，强调她与吉斯家族的家族联系，那个邪恶的法国贵族家庭，那种大天主教徒，将他们描述为既是上帝的敌人，也是欧洲共同安宁的敌人，并强调玛丽与他们的关系。所以这抹黑了诺福克和玛丽，显然是为了塞西尔的目的。这显然是他委托的。而这本小册子的作者，几乎可以肯定是塞西尔的门徒，一个非常冷静、非常微妙的人，像塞西尔一样，也是一个非常坚定的新教徒。这个人将在我们的故事中扮演关键角色。他叫弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆。
Well, he's another very impressive man, isn't he? So he's an ultra-protestant, and he has a sort of, well, didn't Elizabeth call him a rank Puritan? And he has a very sort of Puritan look and sort of vibe to him. He's quite, he looks sort of austere. He wears black. White rough, but otherwise, yeah. White rough, yeah. He's got a sort of watchful, contemplative, subtle, dangerously quiet.
嗯，他也是个非常令人印象深刻的人，不是吗？所以他是一个极端新教徒，他有一种，嗯，伊丽莎白不是叫他“纯粹的清教徒”吗？他有一种清教徒的外表和氛围。他相当，他看起来很严肃。他穿黑色衣服。戴着白色拉夫领，但除此之外，是的。白色拉夫领，是的。他有一种警惕、沉思、微妙、危险的安静。
That's the kind of person he is. Yes. Hooded eyes. But as a double act, I mean, they must be, they must rank alongside. I mean, they're not Keir Stama and Rachel Reeves, that's for sure. I mean, they rank alongside the most effective political double acts in England's history. I think with both of them, their menace and incredible ability kind of shade into one another. They are absolutely not the kind of people that you want to be up against. And that is why Elizabeth employs them.
这就是他那种人。是的。深陷的眼睛。但作为二人组，我的意思是，他们必须排名。我的意思是，他们肯定不是基尔·斯塔默和瑞秋·里夫斯。我的意思是，他们与英国历史上最有效的政治二人组并列。我认为他们两人的威胁和不可思议的能力相互交织。他们绝对不是你想与之对抗的人。这就是伊丽莎白雇用他们的原因。
She recognises how effective they are. playing the role that she as Queen can't. I mean, that's another reason. It's not just that she's a woman. She recognises that she has a role to play as a figurehead for her people, but she needs competent, brilliant people who are doing her work. And Cecil, she's appointed Cecil, Cecil, has appointed Walsingham. So it's kind of working.
她认识到他们有多有效。扮演她作为女王无法扮演的角色。我的意思是，这是另一个原因。不仅仅是因为她是女性。她认识到她作为人民的象征有一个角色要扮演，但她需要能干、聪明的人来为她工作。而塞西尔，她任命了塞西尔，塞西尔任命了沃尔辛厄姆。所以这很有效。
And they're both, I mean, Walsingham, like Cecil, is completely devoted to the regime, isn't he? If Elizabeth Falls, you know, he's for the high jump, effectively. I mean, he's got tremendous qualities. He's a master of tongues, right? He speaks French, Italian. He's traveled in Europe. You know, he's a very impressive and sophisticated person. So he understands how the Catholic powers work.
他们俩，我的意思是，沃尔辛厄姆像塞西尔一样，完全忠于政权，不是吗？如果伊丽莎白倒台，他基本上就完了。我的意思是，他有巨大的品质。他是语言大师，对吧？他会说法语、意大利语。他去过欧洲。他是一个非常令人印象深刻和复杂的人。所以他了解天主教势力是如何运作的。
I mean, he's a consummate kind of cold warrior, if you want to put it like that. He understands the enemy. It's because he understands the enemy that he is so committed to fighting the enemy. And like Cecil, he has no room for complacency. So he thinks it's much better to be paranoid than complacent. And in 1568 he had written to Cecil, there is less danger in fearing too much than too little, which is, I think, a motto not just for the 16th century, but for the ages. I mean, it's the universal motto that all governments should bear in mind. And so he is very committed to supporting Cecil in trying to kind of snuff the flame of Norfolk's insipient rebellion.
我的意思是，他是一个完美的冷战战士，如果你想这样说的话。他了解敌人。正是因为他了解敌人，他才如此致力于打击敌人。像塞西尔一样，他没有自满的余地。所以他认为偏执总比自满好。1568 年，他写信给塞西尔：“担心太多比担心太少危险更小”，我认为这不仅是 16 世纪的座右铭，也是各个时代的座右铭。我的意思是，这是所有政府都应该牢记的普遍座右铭。所以他非常致力于支持塞西尔试图扑灭诺福克初期叛乱的火焰。
And so he suspects that maybe there is a conspiracy that is kind of. of lurking behind Norfolk's approach to Mary Queen of Scots. And sure enough, shortly afterwards, they fix on a guy who seems to be behind the plot. And this isn't an Englishman, but an Italian. And this Italian is taken to Walsingham's house in London and seething alley just by the tower. And it's in this house that this guy is interrogated by Walsingham, who, as you said, speaks Italian. So the interrogation happens in Italian. And the person who's being interrogated is a Florentine, a banker who's been based in London since 1561, and his name is Roberto Rydolfi.
所以他怀疑可能存在一个潜伏在诺福克接触苏格兰女王玛丽背后的阴谋。果然，不久之后，他们锁定了一个似乎是阴谋幕后黑手的人。这不是一个英国人，而是一个意大利人。这个意大利人被带到了沃尔辛厄姆在伦敦的家中，就在塔楼旁边沸腾的小巷里。正是在这所房子里，这个人受到了沃尔辛厄姆的审讯，正如你所说，他会说意大利语。所以审讯是用意大利语进行的。被审讯的人是一个佛罗伦萨人，一个自 1561 年以来一直驻扎在伦敦的银行家，他的名字叫罗伯托·里多尔菲。
And he has been caught red-handed, bringing money into England from the Pope. So the worst of the worst. And he's been giving it to the servants of the Duke of Norfolk. Correct. So this is what Walsingham discovers in the process of his interrogation. not just to the Duke of Norfolk, also to a Scotsman called the Bishop of Ross, who is in London serving Mary Queen of Scots as her agent and ambassador there. So here is the nexus. The Pope is sending money by this guy, Rodolfi, and Rodolfe is then passing the money on to agents of
他被当场抓获，从教皇那里向英格兰运送资金。所以是最坏中的最坏。他一直把钱给诺福克公爵的仆人。没错。这就是沃尔辛厄姆在审讯过程中发现的。不仅给诺福克公爵，还给了一个叫罗斯主教的苏格兰人，他在伦敦担任苏格兰女王玛丽的代理人和大使。所以这就是联系所在。教皇通过这个家伙里多尔菲送钱，然后里多尔菲把钱转交给苏格兰女王玛丽的代理人和诺福克公爵的代理人。而正是诺福克公爵和苏格兰女王玛丽在谈论结婚。我的意思是，这怎么能不对伊丽莎白构成威胁呢？关于里多尔菲阴谋，只有一个问题。没有怀疑他被陷害了吗？多米尼克，这是一部间谍惊悚片。我的意思是，显然，没有什么看起来那么简单。我们说过会有很多曲折。
Mary Queen of Scots and agents of the Duke of Norfolk. And it is the Duke of Norfolk and Mary Queen of Scots who are talking about getting married. I mean, how can this not be a threat to Elizabeth. Just one question about the Rodolfi plot. There's no suspicion that he's been framed. Dominic, this is a spy thriller. I mean, obviously, nothing is quite as it seems. And we've said that there will be lots of twists and turns.
（注：原文索引70与71内容重叠，此处按原文顺序翻译）
We will see. But I think that for Cecil and for Walsingham, what the Rodolfi plot suggests is, first of all, that yes, the Duke of Norfolk is definitely embroiled in an overly treasonous conspiracy. But worse, that this plot does have an international dimension. Because if the Pope's involved, then it suggests that all the kind of the Catholic powers on the continent are probably involved on this. And, you know, the Pope, the Pope has no divisions. But he is the Holy Father to both the kings of France and Spain.
我们会看到的。但我认为对于塞西尔和沃尔辛厄姆来说，里多尔菲阴谋首先表明，是的，诺福克公爵绝对卷入了一个过于叛逆的阴谋。但更糟糕的是，这个阴谋确实具有国际层面。因为如果教皇参与其中，那么这表明大陆上所有的天主教势力可能都参与其中。而且，你知道，教皇，教皇没有军队。但他既是法国国王又是西班牙国王的圣父。
So what might the Pope's agents have been saying to Philip the Second of Spain and to France? And let's come to France first, because of course France is the traditional enemy, always happy to stir up mischief in England, even if you take out the whole Catholic Protestant thing. And Cecil's anxieties about France are focused on this family that we've been mentioning throughout the series, The Gies. And in particular, on one guy in particular who's only 19 years old, he is that the Duke of Gis, Henri the Duke of Gis, but let's call him Henry. And to Protestants in England, Henry of Gies is the absolute archetype of a sinister Catholic
那么教皇的代理人可能对西班牙国王腓力二世和法国说了些什么呢？让我们先谈谈法国，因为法国当然是传统的敌人，即使你抛开整个天主教和新教的问题，也总是乐于在英格兰制造麻烦。塞西尔对法国的焦虑集中在我们整个系列中提到的这个家族——吉斯家族。特别是其中一个只有 19 岁的家伙，他是吉斯公爵，亨利·吉斯公爵，但让我们叫他亨利。对于英格兰的新教徒来说，亨利·吉斯是邪恶天主教马基雅维利主义的绝对原型。所以他是玛丽·斯图亚特的表亲。所以他当然希望她登上英国王位。但他更出名的是因为他是谁的儿子。所以，再次使用一种当代类比，19 岁的亨利·吉斯公爵，被英格兰的新教徒所恐惧，也许就像一个与俄罗斯接壤的国家的人会害怕弗拉基米尔·普京的儿子（如果这样的人存在的话）继承他一样。对。你知道，有一种感觉，父子俩都是坏人，坏家伙，正如特朗普所说的那样。
Machiavell. So he is the cousin of Mary Stewart. So of course he wants her on the English throne. But he's even more notorious because of whose son he is. So again, to pursue a kind of contemporary analogy, Henry Duke of Gies, only 19, is feared by Protestants in England in perhaps the way that people in a country that borders Russia would be afraid of Vladimir Putin's son, if such a person existed, succeeding him. Right. You know, there's a sense that father and son here are both, you know, they're both bad, bad guys, bad enverés, as Trump would call them.
（注：原文索引73与74内容重叠，此处按原文顺序翻译）
It's like one of Saddam's sons or something. Yes, or Gaddafi's. So Henry of Gies's father, Francis, this is the guy who had been Mary Queen of Scotland. Scott's uncle. And so he's the ultimate Cecil Bogieman. He'd also captured Calais and the reign of Mary Tudor. So, you know, that's very bad from an English point of view. He has a very, he had a very, very sinister scar. So that doesn't help. But I think worst of all, and understandably so from Cecil's point of view, in 1562, Francis of Gies had perpetrated an open massacre of French Protestants. And there are a lot of Protestants in France. They're called Huguenot.
就像萨达姆的儿子之一之类的。是的，或者卡扎菲的。所以亨利·吉斯的父亲弗朗西斯，这就是那个曾经是苏格兰女王玛丽的叔叔的人。所以他是终极的塞西尔式恶魔。他还在玛丽·都铎统治时期占领了加来。所以，从英国的角度来看，这非常糟糕。他有一个非常、非常邪恶的伤疤。所以那没用。但我认为最糟糕的是，从塞西尔的角度来看，这是可以理解的，1562 年，弗朗西斯·吉斯对法国新教徒进行了公开屠杀。法国有很多新教徒。他们被称为胡格诺派。
for reasons that are never entirely clear. And in this massacre, 50 Protestants in French Protestants have been left dead, and these included five women and one child. And to Cecil, this massacre serves as evidence of what a Catholic nobleman like the Duke of Norfolk might do in England, given half a chance. And in turn, what the consequences might then be for the stability of the English state, because in France, that massacre perpetrated by Francis of Gies, the father of Henry, of Gies in 1562 had seen the country erupt into full-blown civil war, Catholics against Huguenots.
原因永远不完全清楚。在这场屠杀中，50 名法国新教徒死亡，其中包括五名妇女和一名儿童。对塞西尔来说，这场屠杀证明了像诺福克公爵这样的天主教贵族在英格兰可能会做些什么，如果有机会的话。反过来，这对英格兰国家的稳定可能意味着什么，因为在法国，弗朗西斯·吉斯（亨利·吉斯的父亲）在 1562 年实施的那场屠杀导致国家陷入了全面的内战，天主教徒对抗胡格诺派。
You know, the kind of religious anarchy that Cecil is desperate to stop. And in France, over the course of the 1560s, you'd had massacre after massacre, battle after battle, murder after murder. Now, actually, Henry's father Francis had been, who'd been at the head of the Catholic course, the guy kind of prosecuting the campaign against the huge. He had been assassinated in 1563, so that's the year after the Civil War had broken out by Huguenot Marksman. So we said, this is the age where people are starting to use firearms to kill enemies.
你知道，塞西尔拼命想要阻止的那种宗教无政府状态。在法国，在 16 世纪 60 年代，发生了屠杀接屠杀，战斗接战斗，谋杀接谋杀。实际上，亨利·吉斯的父亲弗朗西斯，那个天主教事业的领导者，那个起诉反对胡格诺派运动的人，在 1563 年被胡格诺派神枪手暗杀，也就是内战爆发后的第二年。所以我们说，这是一个人们开始使用枪支杀死敌人的时代。
But the civil war had blazed on despite the fact that Francis of Guise had been shot. And it's this kind of toxic mix of religious and personal hatreds, as so often happens in civil wars. And Henry, the young Duke of Geese, this guy who is still in his teens, he embodies. He embodies both the sectarian and the personal. So he's absolutely determined to eradicate heresy, Protestantism in France. But he also wants to be avenged on the man that he blames for the assassination of his father. And the guy that Henry of Gies blames for the murder of Francis, his father, is a very distinguished soldier from Burgundy called Gaspar de Coligny.
但尽管弗朗西斯·吉斯被枪杀，内战仍在继续。正如内战中经常发生的那样，这是宗教和个人仇恨的有毒混合物。亨利，年轻的吉斯公爵，这个仍然十几岁的家伙，他体现了这一点。他体现了宗派和个人两方面。所以他绝对决心根除法国的异端和新教。但他还想为他认为是暗杀他父亲的凶手报仇。亨利·吉斯指责谋杀他父亲弗朗西斯的家伙，是一个来自勃艮第的非常杰出的士兵，名叫加斯帕尔·德·科利尼。
And Coligny's had a very, very distinguished career. He'd fought in Italy. He'd become the governor of Paris. the following year he'd become the Admiral of France, which doesn't actually mean that he's sailing around on ships. It means that basically he's number two to the constable of France, who is the kind of the main military officer in the French kingdom. And originally, Coligny and Francis of Guise had been great mates. They hung out at the court. They had a great time, complete lads together.
科利尼有着非常、非常杰出的职业生涯。他在意大利战斗过。他成为了巴黎总督。第二年，他成为了法国海军上将，这实际上并不意味着他在船上航行。这意味着他基本上是法国警卫官的二把手，他是法国王国的主要军事官员。最初，科利尼和弗朗西斯·吉斯是好朋友。他们在宫廷里闲逛。他们玩得很开心，完全是好哥们。
But then in 1558, Colini had to become a Protestant. He had a kind of Calvinist conversion and Calvinist. Calvin, actually, the great Protestant reformer had written to him and they'd become kind of pen pals. And so by the 1560s, he is the leader of the Huguenots in this civil war against the Catholics, against the Gies. And whether Colony had actually commissioned the murder of Henry's father, Henry of Gies' father, is unclear. But definitely, Henry of Gies thinks that Colony had commissioned it. and therefore there is a personal as well as a religious motivation in the fact that the Gis refuse to make peace with the Huguenots.
但后来在 1558 年，科利尼不得不成为新教徒。他有一种加尔文主义的皈依。加尔文，伟大的新教改革家，曾写信给他，他们成了笔友。所以到了 16 世纪 60 年代，他是这场反对天主教徒、反对吉斯家族的内战中胡格诺派的领袖。科利尼是否真的委托谋杀了亨利的父亲，亨利·吉斯的父亲，尚不清楚。但毫无疑问，亨利·吉斯认为科利尼委托了它。因此，吉斯家族拒绝与胡格诺派讲和，这不仅有宗教动机，还有个人动机。
You know, it's personal for them as well as a matter of ideology and principle. And so there's no real prospect, I think, with Colony and Gies at the head of the respective sides in this French Civil War of the wounds being kind of bound up and healed. So when Cessalon and Walsingham look at their map, which they endowed at that, you can imagine them together in the study, looking out over the garden and then looking down on the map and shaking their heads in a sort of performative way. So they see France and they say, well, France is an object lesson in what happens when you have religious tension, when you have plotting, when you have Catholic conspirators, all of this. But then they look slightly to the northeast, so they look
你知道，对他们来说，这既是个人问题，也是意识形态和原则问题。所以，我认为随着科利尼和吉斯分别领导法国内战的双方，伤口被包扎和治愈的前景并不大。所以当塞西尔和沃尔辛厄姆看着他们的地图时，他们对此感到担忧，你可以想象他们一起在书房里，俯瞰花园，然后看着地图，以一种表演性的方式摇头。所以他们看到法国，他们说，好吧，法国是一个关于当你拥有宗教紧张局势、当你拥有阴谋、当你拥有天主教阴谋者时会发生什么的客观教训。但随后他们稍微向东北看，所以他们看
at the low countries and they say, my God, this really is the fate that could await England. because in the low countries, it's total chaos of bloodshed, isn't it? So that's Belgium and Holland, effectively. Yes, because there you have Philip II who rules the low countries. He's their lord. Their Protestantism has put down really quite strong roots. And Philip II as a devout Catholic is absolutely determined to eradicate it for good. So in France, you have civil war between Catholics and Protestants.
向低地国家，他们说，天哪，这真的是可能等待英格兰的命运。因为在低地国家，那是流血的彻底混乱，不是吗？所以那是比利时和荷兰，实际上。是的，因为那里有统治低地国家的腓力二世。他是他们的领主。他们的新教信仰已经扎下了相当深厚的根基。而作为虔诚天主教徒的腓力二世绝对决心彻底根除它。所以，在法国，你有天主教徒和新教徒之间的内战。
And in the low countries, you have a Catholic superpower. trying to crush and stamp out the green shoots of godly religion. And this had been prompted in 1566 by this great firestorm of iconoclastic fury. The Beildenstorm is called in Dutch, which was Protestant mobs kind of running amok, ransacking Catholic churches, smashing up icons and all of that. And Philip is not going to put up with this. So in 1567, he had sent the hardest man in Spain. a guy called the Duke of Alva, who is a Castilian bred of the same steel that had bred Cortez and Pizarro.
而在低地国家，你有一个天主教超级大国。试图粉碎和消灭虔诚宗教的绿色嫩芽。这在 1566 年由这场巨大的破坏偶像狂热的火风暴引发。在荷兰语中被称为“Beildenstorm”，即新教暴徒横行，洗劫天主教教堂，砸碎偶像等等。腓力不会容忍这一点。所以 1567 年，他派出了西班牙最强硬的人。一个叫阿尔瓦公爵的家伙，他是卡斯蒂利亚人，有着培育科尔特斯和皮萨罗同样的钢铁。
Alva is a veteran of wars against the Turks. He fought in Italy, and he is a brilliant general. And he arrives in the low countries with a very large Spanish army. And he sets up this Council of Troubles, it's called, to repress the Protestant insurrection. and the Protestants are very soon calling it the Court of Blood because it leads to mass executions, thousands of people, including very distinguished Protestant nobleman, and huge numbers of Protestants flee this persecution for England. In due course, this persecution will result in one of the momentous episodes in European history, the Dutch Revolt,
阿尔瓦是反对土耳其人战争的老兵。他在意大利战斗过，是一位出色的将军。他带着一支庞大的西班牙军队抵达低地国家。他建立了所谓的“麻烦委员会”来镇压新教起义。新教徒很快称之为“血腥法庭”，因为它导致了大规模处决，数千人，包括非常杰出的新教贵族，大量新教徒逃离这种迫害来到英格兰。到期，这种迫害将导致欧洲历史上最重大的事件之一，荷兰起义，
which we talked about in our episode on the Dutch National Anthem. That was a great episode. But we didn't really talk about that on the impact of all this on England, because in England, the repression and the slaughter in the low countries, it provokes outrage, it provokes horror, it provokes calls for solidarity. Refugees are being given sanctuary in towns and cities across southern England. And I think it definitely consolidates that sense that you were talking about, Dominic, this idea that we still have of Tudor, England, of Elizabethan England, as a land of maypoles and jollity and peace. I think that although clearly there are massive tensions in England, people in England, Catholics, I think as well as Protestants, do look across the seas to France, to the low countries. And they do see this great arc of slaughter and bloodshed. You know, the bodies floating in the Loire, the flames licking barns in Normandy, the corpses littering the streets of Antwerp or whatever.
我们在关于荷兰国歌的那一集中谈到过。那是一集很棒的节目。但我们并没有真正谈论这一切对英格兰的影响，因为在英格兰，低地国家的镇压和屠杀引发了愤怒，引发了恐惧，引发了团结的呼声。难民在英格兰南部的城镇和城市中得到了庇护。我认为这绝对巩固了你所谈论的那种感觉，多米尼克，我们仍然拥有的关于都铎王朝英格兰、伊丽莎白时代英格兰的这种想法，作为一个五朔节花柱、欢乐与和平的土地。我认为，虽然英格兰显然存在巨大的紧张局势，但英格兰的人民，天主教徒和新教徒，确实看向海外，看向法国，看向低地国家。他们确实看到了这道巨大的屠杀和流血的弧线。你知道，漂浮在卢瓦尔河上的尸体，舔舐诺曼底谷仓的火焰，散落在安特卫普街头的尸体等等。
And they do think of Elizabeth as a kind of fairy queen, as she will come to be called. by Spencer. They do think of her as a kind of magical protectors. There's actually a brilliant, it's brilliantly phrased by Garrett Mattingly, who wrote one of my favourite ever books on the defeat of the Spanish Armada. And, you know, that English people in this period see Elizabeth as warding from her island the threatening march of history. And I think there is a kind of sense of that. And that is why Cessal is so desperate to stop the threatening march of history, if you want to put it like that. I think that's true of the Tudors generally, Tom, actually. That's my controversial opinion about the Tudors is people would think of the Tudors as melodramatic and colorful and there's a sense
他们确实把伊丽莎白看作一种仙女女王，正如斯宾塞后来称呼她的那样。他们确实把她看作一种神奇的保护者。实际上，加勒特·马廷利写得非常出色，他写了我最喜欢的关于西班牙无敌舰队失败的书之一。而且，你知道，这个时期的英国人把伊丽莎白看作是从她的岛屿上抵御威胁性的历史进程。我认为有一种那种感觉。这就是为什么塞西尔如此拼命地想要阻止威胁性的历史进程，如果你想这样说的话。我认为这对都铎王朝来说通常是正确的，汤姆，实际上。关于都铎王朝，我的争议性观点是人们会认为都铎王朝是情节剧式的、多彩的，有一种
of instability in soap opera drama. But I actually think the Tudor's great achievement is to keep England fairly stable and united, relatively united. When you look at what's going on on the continent, I mean, it's total bloodshed and chaos. Yeah, absolutely. And Elizabeth has a huge role to play in this. You know, she is the kind of the woman who charms and wooes her own people and who plays hard to get with kind of Catholic suitors on the continent. So, you know, she's magnificent at that. But then you do have Cecil and Walsingham who are hard in the way that you need to be hard to keep your kingdom secure and stable. And so one of the ways in which they display this hardness is that in 1568, four Spanish treasure ships loaded down with the silver from the new world, the mines in Peru. They're chased by pirates and they have to take refuge in English ports. And so Cecil says, well, I think we'll keep it. And the justification for this is that the money was going to be used to fund the Duke of Alva. But it's also the reason that Elizabeth likes it is that she's always short of money. She's incredibly stingy. And so brilliant, we've got this kind of incredible windfall.
不稳定的肥皂剧戏剧感。但我实际上认为都铎王朝的伟大成就是保持英格兰相当稳定和统一，相对统一。当你看看大陆上正在发生的事情时，我的意思是，那是彻底的流血和混乱。是的，绝对。伊丽莎白在这方面发挥了巨大的作用。你知道，她是那种迷住并追求自己人民的女性，也是那种在大陆上与天主教追求者玩弄手段的女性。所以，你知道，她在这方面很出色。但随后你确实有了塞西尔和沃尔辛厄姆，他们以你需要的那种强硬方式来保持你的王国安全和稳定。所以他们展示这种强硬的方式之一是，在 1568 年，四艘装满来自新世界（秘鲁矿山）白银的西班牙宝藏船。它们被海盗追赶，不得不躲进英国港口。所以塞西尔说，好吧，我想我们会留下的。这样做的理由是，这笔钱将被用来资助阿尔瓦公爵。但这也是伊丽莎白喜欢它的原因，因为她总是缺钱。她非常吝啬。所以太棒了，我们有了这种不可思议的意外之财。
There is, of course, a problem with doing this in that it really annoys the king of Spain. And in 1569, of the year following the arrival of these treasure ships in English ports. Cecil writes to Elizabeth and says, you know, very bluntly that you and your government are, and I quote, a most offensive both to the King of Spain and the French king for sundry considerations and especially for succoring of the persecuted. In other words, for taking the side of the persecuted Protestants in France and in the low countries. So to use another analogy from a series we've done on the rest is history. When we talked about the origins of the First World War, I mean, there's a perception
这样做当然有一个问题，那就是它真的惹恼了西班牙国王。在 1569 年，即这些宝藏船抵达英国港口的第二年。塞西尔写信给伊丽莎白说，你知道，非常直率地说，你和你的政府，我引用，“对西班牙国王和法国国王来说都是最冒犯的，出于各种考虑，特别是为了救助受迫害者。”换句话说，为了站在法国和低地国家受迫害的新教徒一边。所以，使用我们在《历史的余味》中做过的系列中的另一个类比。当我们谈到第一次世界大战的起源时，我的意思是，在奥匈帝国这个大国中，有一种看法，
in Austria, Hungary, a big power, that Serbia, a sort of gadfly is fermenting treason and unrest and is giving aid to terrorists and all of that kind of thing. And that lies, you know, it's the heart of the process that leads to the outbreak of the First World War. Well, there must be people in the courts of France and Spain who are saying similar things about England, that England is becoming a rogue state that is supporting terrorists. Completely there are. And so it's an incredible tightrope for Elizabeth and Cecil to walk, to take the measures that enable England to hold her head up and to kind of bulk up her defences and not to allow sand to be kicked in her face, while at the same time trying not to go too far and not provoke kind of, you know,
认为塞尔维亚这个“牛虻”正在煽动叛国和动乱，并向恐怖分子提供援助等等。这位于导致第一次世界大战爆发的过程的核心。好吧，法国和西班牙的宫廷里一定有人在说关于英格兰的类似事情，即英格兰正在成为一个支持恐怖分子的流氓国家。完全有。所以这对伊丽莎白和塞西尔来说是一根不可思议的钢丝，采取使英格兰能够昂首挺胸并加强防御而不允许沙子被踢到她脸上的措施，同时试图不走得太远，不挑起某种，你知道，
say the sending of an enormous fleet up the channel, you know, and I'm ardeth because that would be very bad. And so I think by the late 1660s, you know, 1569 when Cecil wrote that report, It's not surprising that he thinks that things are looking pretty bleak because you have all this bloodshed across the channel, a kind of grim forewarning of what might come to England should he fail in his mission. There's this whole courtship thing between the Duke of Norfolk and Mary Queen of Scots. That's very ominous. Two Catholics, both with royal tudor blood in their veins wanting to get hitched up. I mean, you can't allow that. And then you've got this guy, Rodolfi, who you mentioned.
比如派遣一支庞大的舰队沿海峡而上，你知道，那是无敌舰队，因为那会非常糟糕。所以我认为到 16 世纪 60 年代末，即 1569 年塞西尔写那份报告时，他认为事情看起来相当暗淡并不奇怪，因为海峡对面有所有这些流血事件，如果他在任务中失败，这是一种对英格兰可能发生什么的严峻预警。诺福克公爵和苏格兰女王玛丽之间有整个求爱的事情。那非常不祥。两个天主教徒，都流着皇室都铎血统，想要结婚。我的意思是，你不能允许那样。然后你有了这个家伙，里多尔菲，你提到的。
You know, we talked about him. Is he all that he seems? He seems to have been acting as this conduit between the Pope and the Duke of Norfolk and Mary Queen of Scots. So what's going on with him? So all of these are very worrying. And then in very rapid succession, two further developments. So in December 1569, two Catholic nobleman in the north of England, which we said is the place where probably Catholicism is at its most militant. And these are very, very significant players in the politics of Northern England.
你知道，我们谈到了他。他看起来是那样吗？他似乎一直充当教皇与诺福克公爵和苏格兰女王玛丽之间的渠道。所以他发生了什么事？所以所有这些都非常令人担忧。然后接连发生了两项进一步的发展。所以 1569 年 12 月，英格兰北部的两名天主教贵族，我们说过这是天主教可能最激进的地方。他们是英格兰北部政治中非常、非常重要的参与者。
So Thomas Percy, heir of the Persies, the great family of Northumberland. He's the Earl of Northumberland and Charles Neville, the Earl of Westmoreland, so on the other side of the coast from Northumberland, the pair of them rise in revolt. And their object, they make this clear, is to liberate Mary Stewart and to restore Catholicism. And as an index of this, they capture Durham and they celebrate Mass in Durham Cathedral, the first time since Elizabeth's accession. And Elizabeth is merciless in her repression of this revolt. So 700 of the rebels are hanged and their bodies are left to rot in gibbets. The church bells that had been used to ring the rebellion to raise the rebels are melted down. And those rebels who do manage to escape abroad, which include Westmulland,
所以托马斯·珀西，珀西家族的继承人，诺森伯兰的大家族。他是诺森伯兰伯爵，查尔斯·内维尔，威斯特摩兰伯爵，所以是在诺森伯兰海岸的另一边，两人发动了叛乱。他们的目标，他们明确表示，是解放玛丽·斯图亚特并恢复天主教。作为这一点的标志，他们占领了达勒姆，并在达勒姆大教堂庆祝弥撒，这是自伊丽莎白即位以来的第一次。伊丽莎白对这场叛乱的镇压毫不留情。所以 700 名叛军被绞死，他们的尸体被留在绞刑架上腐烂。用来敲响叛乱钟声以召集叛军的教堂钟声被熔化了。那些确实设法逃往国外的叛军，包括威斯特摩兰，
they will live out their lives on the continent as marked and hunted men. So if we compare Elizabeth's repression of what she sees as heresy with that of Mary's. was responsible for the death of 300 heretics. You know, Elizabeth has sanctioned the execution of 400 more people than that. So the difference, though, is that they have risen in revolt. So if you rise in revolt, you know what you're getting into. Yeah, you could say that. You could say that.
他们将在大陆上作为被标记和被猎杀的人度过余生。所以如果我们比较伊丽莎白对她视为异端的人的镇压与玛丽的镇压。玛丽对 300 名异教徒的死亡负责。你知道，伊丽莎白批准处决的人比那多 400 人。所以区别在于，他们发动了叛乱。所以如果你发动叛乱，你知道你卷入了什么。是的，你可以那样说。你可以那样说。
But, you know, she is at least as robust in her approach to stamping out a sedition as, as Mary was. We are very keen on robust statesmanship of the rest of history, and I just want to make that very clear to all our listeners. We've had this rising of the north, which has been stamped out. But then a few weeks after the suppression of that revolt comes something that is much and much harder to stamp out. Because it doesn't take the form of an armed uprising. It takes the form of a papal bull. And Dominic, a menacing papal bull is nothing that you want to get when you're an embattled Protestant regime.
但是，你知道，她在铲除煽动叛乱方面至少和玛丽一样强硬。我们非常热衷于《历史的余味》中的强硬政治家风度，我只想向我们所有的听众明确这一点。我们经历了这次北方的起义，它已经被镇压了。但就在那次叛乱被镇压几周后，出现了一些更难镇压的东西。因为它不是以武装起义的形式出现的。它以教皇诏书的形式出现。多米尼克，当你是一个陷入困境的新教政权时，一份威胁性的教皇诏书是你不想得到的。
I dread getting a papal bull. I mean, literally the poem postman comes, I worry about a papal bull. So this papal bull is published obviously by the by the pope. That's what makes it papal and this is Pius V. And it's called Regnans in Exegelsis, which is the first line of the bull, which means reigning on high. And by the terms of this bull, the pretended queen of England, as it describes Elizabeth, is excommunicated at last.
我害怕得到教皇诏书。我的意思是，字面上邮递员来了，我担心教皇诏书。所以这份教皇诏书显然是由教皇发布的。这就是它成为教皇诏书的原因，这是庇护五世。它被称为《Regnans in Exegelsis》，这是诏书的第一行，意思是“高高在上统治”。根据这份诏书的条款，正如它所描述的那样，伊丽莎白这位“假定的英格兰女王”终于被逐出教会了。
We said the Pope has been itching to do this. Philip has been kind of holding the Pope on a tight leash. and I think the kind of the Pope takes his chance. Philip is distracted and he kind of publishes it. And this is really, really devastating for Elizabeth and for her government because it doesn't only license English Catholics to renounce their loyalty to Elizabeth. It positively demands it. So to quote the bull, this is the Pope speaking,
我们说过教皇一直渴望这样做。菲利普一直用紧箍咒束缚着教皇，而我认为教皇抓住了机会。菲利普分心了，于是他将其公之于众。这对伊丽莎白和她的政府来说确实是毁灭性的，因为它不仅允许英国天主教徒放弃对伊丽莎白的忠诚，甚至明确要求他们这样做。引用教皇诏书的话，这是教皇在说，
we charge and command all and singular the noble subjects, peoples and others aforesaid that they do not dare obey her orders, mandates and laws. Those who shall act to the contrary, we include in the like sentence of excommunication. So this is really raising the stakes. If you want to stay in the bosom of the church, you must treat Elizabeth as a heretic and as a traitor and ignore her and whatnot.
我们命令并要求所有高贵的臣民、民众及上述其他人，不得胆敢服从她的命令、指令和法律。凡违抗者，我们将处以同样的绝罚。所以这确实提高了赌注。如果你想留在教会的怀抱中，你就必须把伊丽莎白视为异端和叛徒，无视她等等。
But effectively, this goes beyond that because what the Pope is saying, isn't he, is that actually she is a legitimate target now of plotting and indeed of assassination. nation. If you're a good Catholic and you want to, I mean, this is effectively like a fatwa. He's issued a fatwa against Elizabeth I. So it's really bad news. And on top of that, Cecil is pretty clear from intelligence reports that the Pope had kind of been slipping money to the rising in the north. So he's behind that. You've got the Duke of Geese. You've got Henry,
但实际上，这已经超出了这个范畴，因为教皇所说的不正是她现在已成为策划和暗杀的合法目标吗？如果你是一个虔诚的天主教徒，并且你想这样做，这实际上就像是一道教令。他针对伊丽莎白一世发布了一道教令。所以这真是个坏消息。最重要的是，塞西尔从情报报告中非常清楚，教皇一直在向北方的起义提供资金。所以他是幕后黑手。你有吉斯公爵，你有亨利，
the Duke of Geese. You've got the Duke of Alva. They both have massive armies on the other side of the channel from England. steeped in Protestant blood. So that's very bad news. And at the center of the web all along the whole time, the person to whom all these plots are leading back, you have the blood-gourged spider. That is Mary Stewart. And so in 1571, Cecil feels that he's got the proof he needs to go to the queen and say,
吉斯公爵，还有阿尔瓦公爵。他们在英吉利海峡的另一边都拥有庞大的军队，浸透了新教徒的鲜血。所以这是非常糟糕的消息。而一直以来，所有这些阴谋都指向的中心人物，就是那只嗜血的蜘蛛。那就是玛丽·斯图亚特。因此在1571年，塞西尔觉得他已经掌握了所需的证据，可以去见女王并说，
look, we need urgent action. And for two years, so ever since the arrest of Roberto Rodolfi, that Florentine banker, who'd been supplying Norfolk and Mary Stewart with the funds from the Pope. Cecil's agents have been working really hard behind the scenes to bring the full facts of the plot to light. And what their efforts have resulted in is very, very shocking. So Cecil's agents have managed to prove
看，我们需要采取紧急行动。两年来，自从逮捕了那位曾为诺福克和玛丽·斯图亚特提供教皇资金的佛罗伦萨银行家罗伯托·罗多尔菲以来，塞西尔的特工们一直在幕后努力工作，以揭露阴谋的全部真相。他们的努力结果非常令人震惊。所以塞西尔的特工们成功证明了
that the Duke of Norfolk had been plotting to free and then marry Mary, that he and Mary had been working hand in glove, not just with paper ambassadors, but with the French and the Spanish ambassadors in London, that there was to be a rebellion in London, that a Spanish army was to cross from the low countries. So that was why Elizabeth had closed the ports on the eastern coast to stop them from landing there,
诺福克公爵一直在策划释放并迎娶玛丽，他和玛丽一直密切合作，不仅与教皇大使，还与伦敦的法国和西班牙大使勾结，伦敦将发生叛乱，西班牙军队将从低地国家跨海而来。这就是为什么伊丽莎白关闭了东海岸的港口以阻止他们登陆，
and that Mary Queen of Scots was to be proclaimed queen of England. And all of this, you know, it's been done undercover. Cecil wants it out in the public. So he does the classic wheeze of, you know, a leak and he does it in the form of a fabricated letter which gets published and unsurprisingly goes viral. So it's kind of like the equivalent of a newspaper expose. Everybody is reading it and going, oh, this is terrible. And we know for sure the letter was fabricated, right? Yes, we do. So people might be, well, if the letter's fabricated, are the
并且玛丽·斯图亚特女王将被宣布为英格兰女王。所有这些，你知道，都是在秘密进行的。塞西尔想让它公之于众。所以他用了经典的伎俩，你知道，泄密，他以一封伪造信件的形式将其发布，不出所料，这封信疯传开来。所以这就像报纸的曝光报道。每个人都在读它，然后说，哦，这太可怕了。我们确定这封信是伪造的，对吧？是的，我们确定。所以人们可能会想，如果信是伪造的，那么
details necessarily true? And Dominic, you implied that perhaps Cecil was playing a complicated game. I mean, maybe the letter is the expression of what Cecil believes to be true but can't 100% prove, or possibly, Rodolfi, during the process of interrogation by Walsingham, might have been turned and actually become a double agent, have ended up working for Cecil and for Elizabeth's cause. And we will never know, because we don't have the papers to solve this. But I think these are absolutely the right kinds of questions to be asking. There is definitely a sense of a plot there. But who, you know, where exactly the lines are to be drawn in the kind of the balance of all the conspirators is more complex. And just to quote Stephen Orford again in his biography of Cecil, he offers a suggestion that Rodolfi was a plant, that the whole conspiracy was a set up from the start, a plot manufactured by Cecil to expose Mary Stewart for the danger he knew her to be.
细节一定属实吗？多米尼克，你暗示塞西尔可能在玩一场复杂的博弈。我的意思是，也许这封信表达了塞西尔认为真实但无法百分之百证明的事情，或者可能罗多尔菲在沃尔辛厄姆的审讯过程中被策反，实际上成为了双重间谍，最终为塞西尔和伊丽莎白的事业效力。我们永远不会知道，因为我们没有文件来解决这个问题。但我认为这些绝对是应该提出的正确问题。那里确实有一种阴谋感。但究竟谁，你知道，在所有阴谋者的平衡中，界限到底在哪里，这更复杂。引用斯蒂芬·奥尔福德在塞西尔传记中的话，他提出罗多尔菲是一个内应，整个阴谋从一开始就是一个圈套，是塞西尔为了揭露他所知的玛丽·斯图亚特带来的危险而制造的阴谋。
Just to focus in on that for a second, Stephen Alford is not claiming that the whole thing is an utter fiction. What is effectively saying, isn't he, is that Cecil and Walsingham know that the Pope and various other bad people are plotting against England. And they have basically fabricated the evidence, but he's not denying, I mean, the plot definitely, insofar as if plot is the right word, the scheme exists. Yeah, that it does and that they need to expose it and that they do this essentially by turning Rodolfi and getting him to make kind of statements that can then be used. And there is kind of evidence for this. So amazingly, Rodolfi has a private audience with the queen at Greenwich Palace, which is quite odd. Also, when the plot is revealed, Rodolfi is safely back in Italy, where actually, you know,
稍微聚焦一下这一点，斯蒂芬·奥尔福德并不是声称整件事完全是虚构的。他实际上是在说，塞西尔和沃尔辛厄姆知道教皇和其他各种坏人在密谋反对英格兰。他们基本上伪造了证据，但他并不否认，我的意思是，阴谋确实存在，如果阴谋是正确的词的话。是的，它确实存在，他们需要揭露它，他们基本上是通过策反罗多尔菲并让他做出可以被利用的陈述来做到这一点。而且确实有这方面的证据。令人惊讶的是，罗多尔菲在格林威治宫与女王进行了私人会见，这很奇怪。此外，当阴谋被揭露时，罗多尔菲已经安全回到意大利，实际上，你知道，
I mean, if he's a double agent, he then becomes a triple agent because he ends up becoming a papal senator in Florence. and lived to a very ripe old age. I mean, he dies in his 80s. So I think there's a definite, you know, there is a kind of real Lacaree quality to it, smoke and mirrors. You're never entirely sure whose side, Rodolfi is on.
我的意思是，如果他是双重间谍，那么他就变成了三重间谍，因为他最终成为了佛罗伦萨的教皇参议员，并活到了高龄。我的意思是，他80多岁才去世。所以我认为这绝对有一种勒卡雷式的特质，烟雾弹。你永远无法完全确定罗多尔菲站在哪一边。
But I think that while he is in England and being menaced by Cecil, he's on Cecil's side. And then probably when he gets back to Italy, he changes sides again. So he gets off it. But I mean, someone who doesn't get off,
但我认为当他在英格兰并受到塞西尔威胁时，他站在塞西尔这一边。然后当他回到意大利时，他可能又换了阵营。所以他逃脱了。但我的意思是，有人没有逃脱，
Scott Free, is the Duke of Norfolk because he ends up having his head chopped off. He may be Elizabeth. second cousin, and he may be England's preeminent nobleman, but he's been caught bang to rights. But what about Mary Queen of Scots? Sessel is going really hard in, saying to the Queen, look, you cannot be secure on your throne while she is alive. You have to get rid of her. And Elizabeth says no, for the reasons that we've said, you cannot execute one of God's anointed. And there are all kinds of attempts fostered by Cecil, fostered by Walsingham,
逍遥法外，那就是诺福克公爵，因为他最终被砍了头。他可能是伊丽莎白的表弟，也可能是英格兰最杰出的贵族，但他被当场抓获了。但玛丽·斯图亚特女王呢？塞西尔态度非常强硬，对女王说，看，只要她活着，你的王位就不可能稳固。你必须除掉她。伊丽莎白拒绝了，原因正如我们所说，你不能处决上帝的受膏者。塞西尔和沃尔辛厄姆推动了各种尝试，
to get Parliament to try and petition her. So you have the bishops in the House of Lords. The late Scottish Queen have heaped up together all the sins of the licentious sons of David, adultery, murder, conspiracy, treasons and blasphemies against God, and therefore should be put to death. But Elizabeth says no. And Cecil, as a result of this, even as he's triumphant that he's filed the Duke of Norfolk's plot, is kind of plunged into fury and despair at Elizabeth's obduracy as he sees it.
让议会试图请愿处决她。所以你有上议院的主教们说，这位已故的苏格兰女王堆积了放荡的大卫之子们所有的罪孽，通奸、谋杀、阴谋、叛国和亵渎上帝，因此应该被处死。但伊丽莎白拒绝了。结果，塞西尔尽管因挫败了诺福克公爵的阴谋而感到胜利，但对伊丽莎白的固执感到愤怒和绝望。
He just can't believe that he's not allowed to sweep Mary Queen of Scots from the board. But Elizabeth and Cecil, they've had this massive bust up. But Cecil is still confident that he has Elizabeth's backing. You know, she may be capricious and infuriating, but she still trusts him. And I think that's the key to the teamwork that they embody. So in December 1571, Elizabeth expels the Spanish ambassador for his involvement in the Riddolfi plot. And she makes perfectly clear that she believes in the existence of this plot.
他简直不敢相信自己不被允许将玛丽·斯图亚特从棋盘上扫除。但伊丽莎白和塞西尔发生了巨大的争吵。不过塞西尔仍然确信他得到了伊丽莎白的支持。你知道，她可能反复无常且令人恼火，但她仍然信任他。我认为这就是他们所体现的团队合作的关键。因此在1571年12月，伊丽莎白因西班牙大使参与罗多尔菲阴谋而将其驱逐。她明确表示她相信这个阴谋的存在。
So she tells the Spanish ambassador, you would secretly seek to inflame our realm with firebrands. So again, it's so like the Cold War in Britain or the United States where spy networks get exposed in the rush of the Soviet embassy and the Soviet ambassador gets expelled. It's exactly like that. And so Elizabeth knows that she owes Cecil for this. I mean, he may be hassling her to execute Mary Queen of Scots and she's not going to give in to that. But she does know that he has done her in a kind of an amazing turn, you know, that without him, she would be in all kinds of peril. So in February 1571, she bestows a signal honour on him. So William Cecil, this humble Welshman from Lincolnshire. He gets raised to the ranks of the nobility and he's given the title
所以她告诉西班牙大使，你竟然暗中试图用火把点燃我们的王国。所以这再次非常像英国或美国的冷战时期，间谍网络在苏联大使馆的冲击中被曝光，苏联大使被驱逐。完全一样。所以伊丽莎白知道她欠塞西尔一个人情。我的意思是，他可能一直在催促她处决玛丽·斯图亚特，而她不会屈服于此。但她确实知道他以一种惊人的方式帮助了她，你知道，没有他，她将陷入各种危险之中。因此在1571年2月，她授予了他一项特殊的荣誉。所以威廉·塞西尔，这个来自林肯郡的卑微威尔士人。他被提升到贵族行列，并被授予了头衔
the Baron of Burley. And today, you know, people are endlessly being given titles and knighthoods and things by the government. But Elizabeth is much more chary. So it is a huge deal for Cecil to be given this honour. And henceforth he will be known as Lord Burley. And that's what we'll be calling him, Lord Burley. And Lord Burley is on hand to continue his godly war against the threats from Antichrist, whether it be Catholics in England, Mary Queen of Scots, the King of France, the King of Spain,
伯利男爵。今天，你知道，人们不断地被政府授予头衔和爵位等等。但伊丽莎白要谨慎得多。所以对塞西尔来说，获得这一荣誉是一件大事。此后他将被尊称为伯利勋爵。这就是我们将称呼他的名字，伯利勋爵。而伯利勋爵随时准备继续他对反基督威胁的神圣战争，无论是英格兰的天主教徒、玛丽·斯图亚特、法国国王、西班牙国王，
the Pope, they are all still out there and they are all still looking to menace the Protestants of England and the reign of Good Queen Bess. Well it's actually, I mean, not only are they still looking to do it, but actually the threats are becoming more and more serious, aren't they? And the skies are
教皇，他们都还在那里，他们都还在试图威胁英格兰的新教徒和好女王贝丝的统治。嗯，实际上，我的意思是，他们不仅还在试图这样做，而且实际上威胁正变得越来越严重，不是吗？天空正
getting darker and darker. Because just 12 weeks after the execution of the Duke of Norfolk, who I think everybody agrees had it coming. That was on the 24th of August 1572. Twelve weeks later, something happens in the streets of Paris that sends shockwaves through Protestant Europe.
变得越来越阴暗。因为就在诺福克公爵被处决12周后，我想大家都同意他是罪有应得的。那是1572年8月24日。12周后，巴黎街头发生了一件事，在整个新教欧洲引起了震动。
And this is a pogrom, a massacre beyond even Cecil's worst nightmares, the massacre of St. Botholomew's Day. And on hand to see it is the other person we've been talking about today, Francis Walsingham, who had been sent by Elizabeth I
这是一场大屠杀，甚至超出了塞西尔最糟糕的噩梦，即圣巴托罗缪大屠杀。当时在场的还有我们今天谈到的另一个人，弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆，他被伊丽莎白一世派往
to serve as her and in France. And what Walsingham sees that day in Paris will never leave him. It's stamped on his imagination for the rest of his life as it is stamped on the imaginations of everybody in England. And it confirms him and Cecil in all their darkest suspicions of the Papist Catholic menace and their dread of the Catholic enemy within. And Tom, we will be telling that story, won't mean next time, as part of this epic sweep through the rain. of Elizabeth I will be telling the story of St. Bartholome's Day Massacre. We will be looking at the career of one of England's greatest heroes, Francis Drake,
法国担任她的特使。沃尔辛厄姆那天在巴黎所见的一切将永远不会离开他。它印在他的余生记忆中，就像它印在英格兰每个人的记忆中一样。它证实了塞西尔和他对教皇天主教威胁的所有最黑暗的怀疑，以及他们对内部天主教敌人的恐惧。汤姆，我们下次会讲那个故事，作为伊丽莎白一世统治时期史诗般叙事的一部分，我们将讲述圣巴托罗缪大屠杀的故事。我们将审视英格兰最伟大的英雄之一弗朗西斯·德雷克的职业生涯，
who I think some people have very sadly questioned in that these days. And we will also be looking at the road to the Spanish Armada, the attempt by Philip of Spain finally to crack down on what he sees as England's rogue terrorist Protestant states. So there's loads of exciting drama to come. members of the Rest is History Club, they can hear all those episodes right now. So they're the members of our own rogue state. If you want to join them,
我想现在有些人非常遗憾地质疑他。我们还将审视通往西班牙无敌舰队之路，即西班牙的菲利普最终试图镇压他所认为的英格兰流氓恐怖主义新教国家的尝试。所以还有很多激动人心的戏剧性事件即将到来。Rest is History俱乐部的成员现在就可以听到所有这些剧集。所以他们是我们自己流氓国家的成员。如果你想加入他们，
if you want to cross the divide and come over to God's own side, then head to the restishistory.com and sign up. It is actually what God would have wanted and indeed where Elizabeth I would have wanted. And of course, if you want to read lots about this, there is no better place than the rest is history's newsletter.
如果你想跨越鸿沟，来到上帝的一边，那就前往restishistory.com并注册。这实际上是上帝所希望的，也是伊丽莎白一世所希望的。当然，如果你想阅读更多关于这方面的内容，没有比Rest is History的时事通讯更好的地方了。
So you can sign up. up to the newsletter as well for free, and you'll be getting all kinds of interesting tip bits about the reign of Elizabeth. The first. I say tip bits, but actually articles, interviews, book extract, you name it. We've got loads of fun things coming up. So on that bombshell, thank you very much, Tom. We will see you next time for the massacre of St. Barthonymy's Day. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Hey, y'all. It's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what-if. Just style you love and quality you can trust.
所以你也可以免费注册时事通讯，你将获得关于伊丽莎白一世统治时期的各种有趣花絮。我说花絮，但实际上是文章、采访、书籍摘录，应有尽有。我们有很多有趣的内容即将推出。那么，就在这个重磅消息上，非常感谢你，汤姆。我们下次再见，讲述圣巴托罗缪大屠杀。再见。再见。嘿，大家好。我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具并想过，如果呢？比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有如果。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。
Visit wayfair.ca. Wayfair, every style, every home. Hello, everybody. We have absolutely sensational, spectacular, stupendous news about a forthcoming Restis History live show. We do, Dominic. Now, sometimes there are complaints that people in Britain don't know enough about the British Empire,
访问wayfair.ca。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。大家好。我们有一个关于即将到来的Rest is History现场演出的绝对轰动、壮观、惊人的消息。我们有，多米尼克。现在，有时有人抱怨英国人对大英帝国了解不够，
that they don't study it in sufficient depth. So we are stepping in to make up for that. And we are going to be telling the story of the ultimate Victorian imperial. adventure. And that Dominic is the Abyssinian expedition of 1868. And it's, well, I dare say it's brilliant, but it's mad, isn't it? It is mad. To give people a bit of context, it's an amazing story. The emperor of Abyssinia to Wadros II, he was ignored by Queen Victoria, who didn't answer his letters. So he took some British hostages, and then the British sent an expedition
他们没有进行足够深入的研究。所以我们正在介入以弥补这一点。我们将讲述终极维多利亚时代帝国冒险的故事。多米尼克，那就是1868年的阿比西尼亚远征。而且，嗯，我敢说它很精彩，但它很疯狂，不是吗？确实很疯狂。给人们一点背景，这是一个惊人的故事。阿比西尼亚皇帝特沃德罗斯二世，他被维多利亚女王忽视了，她没有回他的信。所以他扣押了一些英国人质，然后英国人派出了远征军
to Abyssinia to attack his capital at Magdalar, his kind of mountain citadel. It's an amazing, amazing story, a bonkers story, and precisely the kind of thing that we enjoy on the rest is history. Yes, and that I think the entire country could profit from hearing about. So that is what we're going to be doing. It is, I think, a very flashman kind of a story. Totally. So anyone who enjoys Flashman will enjoy this. And we are going to be doing it at the South Bank Centre in London on the 4th of September. We do have a few tickets for that. We're also doing it on the 5th of September and not to base, but that one is already sold out. So if you want to come, book your tickets for the 4th of September and you can get them at the rest is history.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
前往阿比西尼亚攻击他的首都马格达拉，他那座山上的堡垒。这是一个令人惊叹的故事，一个疯狂的故事，正是我们在Rest is History中喜欢的那种东西。是的，我认为整个国家都能从听到这个故事中获益。所以这就是我们要做的。我认为这是一个非常像弗莱什曼的故事。完全正确。所以任何喜欢弗莱什曼的人都会喜欢这个。我们将于9月4日在伦敦南岸中心进行演出。我们确实还有一些票。我们也会在9月5日演出，但那场已经售罄了。所以如果你想来，请预订9月4日的票，你可以在restishistory.com上买到。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。